Die Flenke von Kraftwerk und ein Blick auf den Kalender. Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat. Sollten euch zur Erkenntnis bringen, dass es natürlich Zeit ist für das Chaosradio auf Fritz, zu dem herzlich begrüßt seid. Teil 144 heute zu Gast in Starbucks und der Chef persönlich, Peter Frank, guten Abend. Wir reden heute über ein Thema, was am Anfang heute tags über mir gegenüber kommentiert wurde mit den Worten ach du Gott, das ist ja nun totaler Nerdveranstaltung. Es geht um Datenträger, Datenverlust und Datenrettung. Aber ich glaube gar nicht, dass es so eine Nerdveranstaltung ist, weil jeder von uns und auch jeder von euch irgendwann mal schon in der vergangenen Zeit sich darüber geärgert hat, dass Daten, die euch wichtig waren, dass ihr die irgendwo hingeschoben habt und danach waren sie nicht mehr da, wo ihr sie eigentlich vermutet bzw. ihr konntet sie nicht mehr zurückholen und saß dann vor dem großen schwarzen Loch. Wie das zu umgehen ist und was es da alles zu beachten gibt, das wollen wir heute im Laufe der Sendung klären, an der ihr euch natürlich auch gerne beteiligen könnt unter 0331 70 97 110. Aber bevor wir uns in die Welt der Festplatten, USB-Speicher und sonstiger Geschichten bewegen, gibt es noch mal ein kleines Update. Denn heute gerade gab es im Bundestag eine Entscheidung zu einer Debatte, die seit langer Zeit geführt wird, auch hier in der vorletzten Sendung von Chaosradio, von vor zwei Wochen. Es geht um die geplante Zensur vom Internet bzw. die Sperrung von expliziten Webseiten. Starbucks hat dazu noch einen kleinen Vortrag ausgearbeitet.
Also ich hab mich gerade schon massiv in Rage geredet. Also das, wie ihr wahrscheinlich alle mitgekriegt habt, war heute, die Regierung hat beschlossen, jetzt doch mal ein Gesetz auf den Weg zu bringen, um Internetinhalte zu filtern. Also man kann es halt wirklich nicht anders sagen. Das ist halt einfach wirklich eine Filterung bzw. eine Zensur von Inhalten. Aus der Grund, den sie genannt haben, der natürlich irgendwie sehr naheliegend ist und auch sehr passend ist, um so ein Gesetz durchzubringen im Endeffekt, ist Kinderpornografie, weil gegen Kinderpornografie sich halt ziemlich schwierig gegen argumentieren lässt. Also wir haben es halt auch immer wieder versucht, mit technischen Daten zu argumentieren. Und sie sagen auch selber, dass es technisch nahezu unmöglich ist, diese Filterlisten wirklich durchzusetzen. Aber im Endeffekt ist es halt irgendwie eines der wenigen Themen, wo sich die Große Koalition irgendwie noch eigentlich sind. Und deswegen rechnen wir halt einfach damit, dass es noch in dieser Legislaturperiode ein Gesetz dazu geben wird. Und das ist ja wirklich mal so die Kacke am Dampfen sozusagen, was irgendwie das Inhalt betrifft. Also danach wird halt einfach in Deutschland nix mehr so sein wie vorher. Also was sie halt wirklich vorhaben ist, die großen Provider zu verpflichten, Internet-Sperrinfrastruktur bei sich aufzubauen. Das heißt irgendwie jeder Benutzer, der auf eine Seite raufklicken will, die Nachmeinung des, ja, Insertior, wer auch immer schuld ist, irgendwie hier. Also es ist halt wirklich auch noch ganz unklar, wer halt diese Listen überhaupt verwaltet.
Im Moment geht es über, ist geplant, dass es das Bundeskriminalamt machen wird.
Also nach den neuesten Gesetzesvorlagen, beziehungsweise nach dem, was sie heute in der Regierung, wie gesagt haben, ist es nicht mehr das Bundeskriminalamt. Also sie haben jetzt wirklich offen gelassen, wer diese Filterlisten führt. Also auf jeden Fall geht es halt darum, dass irgendeine Institution in Deutschland Filterlisten zur Verfügung stellt, die innerhalb von wenigen Stunden bei jedem Provider in Deutschland eingearbeitet werden müssen. Das heißt, wenn Benutzer, also Internetsurfer, auf einen dieser Domains draufklicken wollen, dass sie dann mit so einem Narvanen-Hinweis konfrontiert werden und sagen, wie die Seite, die sie gerade aufgerufen haben, entspricht nicht der legalen Internet, was auch immer. Und wenn sie sich, also bei Fragen wenden sie sich irgendwie an ihr BKA. Das heißt, sie bauen damit wirklich eine Zensurinfrastruktur auf und damit sind wirklich die Missbrauchstür und Tor geöffnet. Also jetzt, sie behaupten, oder sie wollen es in ein Gesetztext natürlich reinschreiben, dass es nur auf kinderpornografische Seiten angewendet ist. Aber es haben sich auch schon genug andere Institutionen, wie zum Beispiel die Gerechteverwerter gemeldet, dass sie dann auch zum Beispiel Pirate Bay oder irgendwie so Seiten, die nach ihrer Meinung illegalen Content anbieten.
Es ist wie immer, wenn es eine technische Struktur gibt, gibt es ganz viele Befindlichkeiten und Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, von Musikindustrie über Spielehersteller, über Softwarehersteller und alle möglichen Leute, die natürlich ihre Rechte gewahrt haben wollen.
Genau. Und hier ist es halt so, dass die Politiker selber nicht wirklich wissen, was sie sich damit eingebrockt haben. Weil diese Infrastruktur so dermaßen missbraucht werden kann, dass der Nutzen im Gegensatz, also der eigentlich nicht vorhandene Nutzen im Gegensatz zu den schädlichen Nachwirkungen, halt so groß, so gering ist, dass halt eigentlich klar sein müsste. Aus technischer Sicht ist es halt einfach irrsinnig, das umzusetzen. Also die Filterlisten basieren halt auf Domain Names, also das, was man in der URL oben eintippt. Das heißt, jeder, der auch nur halbwegs mit seinem Browser umgehen kann, kann oben die IP-Adresse eingeben oder ein Proxy angeben und damit halt diese Sperrlisten umgehen.
Das ist das, was dann bei den Internet-Ausdruckern immer heißt, versierte Internetnutzer wissen es trotzdem zu knacken.
Genau, sagt die Frau van der Leyen irgendwie in dem Fall. Aber das ist natürlich irgendwie Harnenbüchen. Also jeder, also jedes Kind heutzutage wird diese Sperrfilter umgehen können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir natürlich dann die Listen, die halt irgendwie dann natürlich auch veröffentlicht werden müssen oder zumindest bei den Providern ankommen müssen. Und dort haben natürlich die Kinder-Porno-Benutzer oder irgendwie Konsumenten die beste Liste, die Top 10 der deutschen Kinder-Pronoseiten, die sie dann halt irgendwie freihaus anzursurfen können. Also eigentlich ist es halt wirklich ein gegenteiliger Effekt. Und das ist das große Problem auch, dass halt einfach die Seiten halt nicht verschwinden. Das heißt, die Politiker wissen, auf welchen Servern die existent sind, diese Seiten. Das sind teilweise Server, die in Deutschland stehen. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich dem Übel auf der Wurzel, auf den Grund gehen wollte, dann müsste man halt einfach nur zu den Providern gehen, wo dieses Server gehostet werden und sagen, ihr habt dort illegalen Content drauf, nehmt den mal runter. Was sie halt irgendwie jetzt tun, ist eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen, halt Sachen zu filtern und damit halt nicht mal wirklich den, die Grundlage halt irgendwie aus Acht zu lassen, sondern zu versuchen, also wie gesagt, logisch ist es halt einfach nicht, nicht zu verstehen aus unserer Sicht. Was sie halt damit aufbauen, ist halt eine ganz kleine, große Gefahr für die Demokratie eigentlich, also für das ganze Internet.
Mehr Informationen dazu findet ihr auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es nämlich den Podcast der vorletzten Sendung, wo wir zwei Stunden lang in aller Ausführlichkeit über die Zensur vom Internet gesprochen haben. Das ist heute eigentlich gar nicht das Thema. Eine letzte Frage hab ich noch. Es gab ja in den Wochen und Monaten vor dieser heutigen Entscheidung, was ja noch keine Entscheidung ist, sondern sie haben ja nur gesagt, wir müssen mal ein Gesetz machen, gab es sehr viele kritische Stimmen, es gab sehr viele Anmerkungen zum Thema. Das ist nur ein kleiner Bruchteil von dem, was ihr eigentlich machen wollt. Das geht nach hinten los, es wird eine Infrastruktur der Zensur geschaffen. Also es gab ganz viele kritische Stimmen, die sich dazu geäußert haben. Habt ihr ganz persönlich den Eindruck, dass das so verpufft ist, dass das einfach an den Ohren von Frau von der Leyen und Co. vorbeigegangen ist?
Also wir haben das Gefühl, dass es halt mit Absicht, also man hat uns beim BSI-Gesetz, zum Beispiel beim WKA-Gesetz, haben sie es halt immer schon versucht irgendwie einzubringen. Dort war die Kritik halt ausreichend groß und sie versuchen es halt immer wieder, bis sie die Gesetze irgendwie durchbringen. Also was wir halt bei anderen Gesetzen irgendwie auch in letzter Zeit schon gesehen haben, sie versuchen halt wirklich ihre repressiven Gesetze durchzubringen. Wenn es halt irgendwie auf die eine oder andere Weise nicht klappt, versuchen sie halt einfach in zwei Monaten nochmal und irgendwann sind die Stimmen halt verstummt und irgendwie keine ausreichend kritischen Stimmen mehr da und dann bringen sie es halt einfach durch. Und Kinderpornografie ist natürlich ein Thema, wo man auf technischer Ebene halt sehr schwer dagegen argumentieren kann. Also technisch sind diese Filter halt wirklich total sinnlos, aber das reicht halt irgendwie genau von der Gegenseite halt ein Argument. Aber die armen Kinder und irgendwie schon bist du halt irgendwie durch mit der Diskussion. Das ist halt ganz schwierig da wirklich sinnvoll gegen zu argumentieren.
Reduzieren wir es mal auf eine einfache Matheaufgabe, die heißt Vorratsdatenspeicherung plus Internetzensur plus biometrische Chipkarten, Datenausweise und Krankenkarten ist gleich Deutschland im Jahre 2009. Willkommen im Chaosradio auf Ritz. Das sind alles Themen, die uns beschäftigen, aber nicht heute. Weil heute reden wir über geschredderte Daten, Daten, die zu schreddern sind und Daten, die ihr eigentlich gerne gesichert haben wollt, aber nicht so richtig wisst, wie das geht. Das ist das Thema der heutigen Sendung. Wir hören jetzt ein kurzes Stückchen Musik, um eine Pause zu machen. Es gibt übrigens auch eine Playliste zu der Sendung auf fritz.de beziehungsweise chaosradio.ccc.de da gibt es dann den Link natürlich auch. Ihr werdet das schon finden, ihr seid ja cleverer Kerlchen. Heute ist Mittwoch, der 25. März, wir sind im 144. Chaos Radio. Peter Frank ist da und Starbuck ist auch bei uns und wir reden über Datenträger, Datenverlust und Datenrettung. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen unter der 0331 70 97 110 und eure Horrorgeschichten von gecrasheden Daten, von verschwundenen Daten und von nie wiederrettbaren Daten zu erzählen. Vielleicht finden wir heute eine gemeinsame Lösung, wie das alles relativ einfach und unkompliziert zu machen ist. Aber am Anfang sollten wir vielleicht mit der Basis beginnen, mit den Medien oder den Devices, auf denen Daten zu speichern sind.
Ja, und da sage ich jetzt mal, werden heute eigentlich immer noch die meisten Daten auf Festplatten gespeichert. Das sind rotierende magnetische Datenspeicher. Ich gebe erst mal so einen kleinen Überblick, womit wir uns eigentlich heute im Wesentlichen zu beschäftigen haben. Dann die zweite große Gruppe sind Flashmedien. Das sind Halbleiterspeicher. Die kommen in verschiedenen Darreichungsformen. USB-Sticks hat jeder. Kleine Kärtchen, die man in Kameras oder mp3-Player oder Handys reinsteckt.
Also alles, was nicht rotiert?
Ja, also da...
Festspeicher.
Um da beim Bild zu bleiben.
Also die rotieren eigentlich nur, wenn man sie in die Hand nimmt und am Bändchen um die Hand schleudert.
Oder frustriert in die Ecke haut, weil es nicht mehr lesbar ist.
Also das sind mal so die Flash-Medien, die kommen mittlerweile auch schon in Verpackungen von konventionellen Festplatten da her. Die nennt man dann Solid-State-Discs. Ist aber technisch im Grunde genommen dasselbe, was im USB-Stick drin ist. Und auch in diesen ganzen Flash-Karten.
Aber im Hype um Technik... Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich immer wieder unterbreche. Aber im Hype um technische Entwicklung sind Solid-State-Discs oder SSDs im Moment ja das heiße Ding, weil die ja demnächst in Laptops eingebaut werden sollen. Und dann ist der Laptop zu groß in Geschwindigkeit.
Haben halt einfach mal den großen Wort, dass sie halt wirklich keine beweglichen Teile haben. Also deswegen halt um die Solid-State. Und deswegen natürlich auch sehr viel weniger anfällig für Zerstörung oder für Defekte sind. Und worum es nachher irgendwie noch gehen wird.
Wahrscheinlich aber auch nicht das Ei des Kolumbus.
Die sitzen ja eh schon in Laptops drin. Also diese Ultralight Laptops von, also dieser X31 von ehemals IBM und jetzt Linruvo, der hat die meines Erachtens schon serienmäßig drin. Insofern kommen die nicht, die sind schon da. Aber im Grunde genommen technisch ist das nicht so interessant, weil wir sie eigentlich schon immer gehabt haben. Wir haben sie schon in Form von Kamerakärtchen und MP3-Playern und USB-Sticks gehabt. Das Einzige, was sich daran geändert hat, ist halt die Gehäuseform und die Schnittstelle.
Na und die Größe vor allem, die verfügbare. Also wo man irgendwie, also sie nähern sich so langsam wirklich den Festplattengrößen an. Es ist halt immer noch so ein Faktor 10 ungefähr oder irgendwie 5 vom Unterschied, aber schon, sodass man langsam sagen kann, wenn man ein neues Not bekauft, keine Festplatte mehr, so eine Haltung wie wirklich ein Festspeicher.
Na ganz stimmt das nicht, denn die Festplatten, die Festplattenkapazität explodiert ja ungefähr mit der gleichen Explosionsrate wie die Flashkapazität, nicht? Ich meine, jetzt sind die ersten zwei Tera-Arbeitplatten auf dem Markt. Ist ja auch egal. Ich wollte erst mal einen Überblick geben, über die Einzelheiten können wir noch reden.
Genau.
Dann haben wir als nächstes die optischen Medien, die sind auch noch nicht tot. Da haben wir jetzt eben erst die CDs gehabt, dann die DVDs und jetzt halt so diese 50 Gigabyte-Scheibchen, Blu-rays und wie sie alle heißen. Und ich denke, die werden uns auch noch eine Weile begleiten. Und dann gibt es noch so, sage ich jetzt mal, so komplexere Gebilde. Das sind so Netzwerkspeicher. Dahinter verbergen sich im Grunde genommen Disk-Arrays, also größere Mengen von meistens rotierenden Datenspeichern, die in irgendwelchen Schränken drin sind und über irgendwelche kabellängere, manchmal viele tausend Kilometer lange Kabel mit meinem Rechner verbunden sind.
Auch noch Magnetbänder? Also wird heutzutage noch wirklich Magnetbänder eingesetzt?
Das war jetzt eigentlich genau der nächste Punkt, auf den ich kommen wollte, dass nämlich Magnetbänder eigentlich de facto in der Massenanwendung tot sind. Es gibt sie noch in einigen Spezialbereichen, wo sie sinnvoll sind, aber Magnetbänder sehen wir, zumindest in der Datenrettung immer seltener, es sei denn, es geht um Konvertierung, denn es gibt noch viele große Keller, die voll liegen mit Magnetbändern, wo unter Umständen noch nicht mal die Inhaltsverzeichnisse bekannt sind. Das heißt, das muss alles noch aufgearbeitet werden. Und da ist auch unsere Industrie mit befasst, diese großen Archive zumindest mal zu katalogisieren. Und da hat man im Wesentlichen noch mit Magnetbändern zu tun, sag ich jetzt mal, in den Altbeständen. Neu wird sowas kaum noch hergestellt. Also ich sag mal, als Beispiel, kürzlich hatte ich eine Maschine auf dem Tisch, das war so ein Plattenschränkchen, was dazu da war, zwischen einem Magnetband-Roboter und dem eigentlichen Backup-Programm zu stecken, weil der Magnetband-Roboter nicht schnell genug war, die Daten wegzuschreiben. Also hat man einen Plattenschrank dazwischen getan, der das Magnetband simuliert, aber die Daten schneller annehmen kann.
Das klingt total nach Daniel Lüse.
Und dann nach hinten raus, die dann langsam wegschreibt, nachdem das Backup schon längst passiert ist.
Du hast gerade gesagt, es gibt einige Spezialbereiche, in denen Magnetbänder immer noch eingesetzt werden. Was sind das für Spezialbereiche?
Ein Klassiker ist Video zum Beispiel. Man hat ja nach wie vor diese Mini-DV-Kassetten. Das sind ja letztlich auch Datenbänder. Ist technisch nichts anderes als ein Backup-Band eigentlich. Ansonsten gibt es eigentlich kaum noch. Die Backup-Bänder, wie wir sie früher gehabt haben, Kassette in den PC reinstecken und vor und zurück. Das ist so gut wie tot. Das wird heute eigentlich durch Platten-Technik ersetzt.
Das Ding, was jetzt demnächst kommt, sind SSDs, also Solid-State-Discs, Flash-Speicher, die ausgebaut werden und immer noch die gute alte Hard-Disc, die Festplatte.
Genau, für die ganz großen Eisen wird die Festplatte so schnell nicht ausgedient haben, weil einfach die Kapazität nach wie vor in absurden Größenordnungen wächst.
Haben wir noch so andere optische Speicher, also holographische Speicher, gibt es noch nicht wirklich im Einsatz, oder?
Ich hab sowas schon mal materialisieren sehen, aber die sind im kommerziellen Einsatz eigentlich, haben die keine Bedeutung im Moment.
War das so die Übersicht über die gerade vorhandenen Geräte?
Genau.
Dann lass uns doch gleich mal irgendwie ins Telefon greifen und Axel ans Telefon nehmen, weil Axel ist ein Oldschooler.
Axel ist Physiker.
Guten Abend, Axel.
Hallo Jakob.
Und sichert immer noch mit Magnetbändern.
Ja, aber natürlich.
Axel, du weißt aber schon, dass wir im 22. Jahrhundert fast leben.
Ja, natürlich, aber ohne Magnetbänder geht's nicht. Also wir haben wirklich noch große Magnetbandschränke und wir haben genau die Technik...
Du meinst, wir bei euch auf Arbeit.
Wir bei uns auf Arbeit, ja.
Wo arbeitest du denn?
Bei Bessie, Benina Elektronik, bei der Synchrotronenstrahlung. Also, sprich, Messdatenanfall vom Allerfeinsten in größten Ordnung. Und die müssen einfach auch auf einem virtuellen Bandlaufwerk, sprich auf dem beschriebenen Plattenschrank zwischengespeichert werden.
Ah, da ist er ja.
Weil das Bandlaufwerk mich hinterherkommt.
Genau. Warum sprecht ihr denn überhaupt noch auf Bandlaufwerken? Wegen der Kapazität oder?
Weil wir die Sachen archivieren müssen.
Ja, aber man kann das irgendwie auch auf Platten archivieren oder?
Ja, dann stellt man die Platten in den Schrank. Zur Zeit sagen wir mal so, wir haben diesen und jenen, der auch mal bei der Plattenherstellung gearbeitet hat. Und normalerweise geben die Plattenhersteller auch nur noch drei Jahre Garantie auf Unveränderlichkeit der Daten, wenn man sie nicht wieder überschreibt.
Das heißt, das ist dann unter Sicherheitsaspekten nicht zulässig, so was zu haben?
Das ist nicht so richtig. Ich meine, die Bänder sollte man auch jedes Jahr neu schreiben.
Es geht wirklich um die Langlebigkeit der Daten?
Es geht um die Langlebigkeit. Und der zweite Schritt ist der, der jetzt zur Zeit ja in Europa ganz groß sein wird, eine europaweite Verfügbarkeit aller Messdaten an allen physikalischen Einrichtungen. Das heißt, ich logge mich heute in Berlin bei Bessy und nächste Woche bei der ESRF in Grenoble und dann irgendwann bei Diamond in der Nähe von Oxford ein und habe immer Zugriff auf denselben Datensatz.
Das ist aber eigentlich ja, aus meiner Sicht, ist das ja eigentlich eher ein Plädoyer für Festplatten, weil bis ich dann das Band geladen hab, bin ich ja ein alter Mann geworden.
Das ist gar nicht so lange. Die Jungs von der DRR in München machen sowas und die sagen, bei Daten, die irgendwie älter als zwei Jahre sind, brauchen sie eine endliche Zeit, die aber auch im Minutenbereich liegt, das rauszusuchen.
Also die haben dann wirklich irgendwie fertige Roboter, die dann die Bänder raussuchen?
Eine Frage hab ich noch. Ist das, was ihr da betreibt, ist das jetzt im Prinzip so eine Art Bandcache oder ist das ein richtiges HSM, also ein hierarchisches Storage System? Na gut, da läuft die Sache noch ein bisschen anders, denn beim HSM, da steckt noch ein bisschen mehr dahinter. Da wird ja auch für die Redundanz gesorgt. Das heißt, die Daten sind da ja nicht nur einmal. Das ist auch, das ist unabhängig noch davon, welche Datenträger man einsetzt, muss man eben, wenn einem die Daten wirklich wichtig sind, auch für ein entsprechendes Maß an Redundanz sorgen. Und in diesem hierarchischen Storage System wird eben vollautomatisch diese Redundanz aufrecht erhalten. Und insofern ist das noch ein anderes, ist das noch ein bisschen was anderes, als jetzt ein reiner, also wie soll ich sagen, als jetzt ein reiner Testsimulator, der jetzt nur aus Geschwindigkeitsgründen cached.
Der sozusagen virtuell sagt, ich bin jetzt Bandlaufwerk.
Genau.
Der auf der Gegenseite einfach vorgab, ich bin jetzt Bandlaufwerk, weil diverse Sicherungssoftware schreibt wirklich gnadenlos nur auf Bandlaufwerke. Das heißt, ich muss der Software beibiegen, schreibe jetzt auf ein Bandlaufwerk, dabei ist es gar keins.
Genau. Und dafür, ich meine, da werden jetzt neuerdings sehr gerne Eisgasi-Systeme eingesetzt, weil man nämlich in einem Eisgasi-Target sagen kann, du bist ein Band oder du bist eine Platte oder du bist eine Bit-Raus-Tröpfel-Maschine. Und der Initiator glaubt das einfach.
Das ist ein Eisgasi.
Ich muss jetzt schon erklären.
Und du hast vor allem noch zwei Minuten ein bisschen Nachdenken.
Ich hab nur noch zwei Minuten. Okay, ich erkläre in zwei Minuten ein Eisgasi. Einverstanden?
Warte mal, bevor du Eisgasi erklärst, eine Frage noch an Axel, damit wir eine Dimension der Größenordnung kriegen. Du hast gesagt, es fallen bei euch Messdaten ohne Ende an und ihr archiviert die auf Band. Wie groß ist denn dieses Archiv? So zwei Fußballfelder unterirdisch?
Also unterirdisch ist es schon. Also es ist im Keller. Damit es ist nicht so richtig unterirdisch. Und es ist auch kein Hochsicherheitsbunker. Und es ist auch noch kein feuersicherer Schrank um das ganze Bandlaufwerksystem. Also die Bänder selber lagern in feuersicheren Schränken. Aber es ist nicht die ganze Maschine noch.
Na sag mal, wie groß dieser Raum ist.
Puh, äh, frag mich. Schwer zu schätzen.
Fußballfeld.
Fußballfeld ist schon ein größerer Raum.
100 oder 1000 Quadratmeter?
Naja, eher 100, nicht 1000.
Alles klar.
Eher 100, aber ich hab noch eine Frage.
Ne, vorher waren wir zu einem Eiskasi.
Ja, aber mach das mal, das Eiskasi. Weil passt in denselben Zusammenhang, aber...
Vielleicht können wir deine Frage nach den Nachrichten klären, Axel. Ja, dann bereise ich kurz zusammen mit deiner Frage. Wir klären jetzt noch Eiskasi, machen dann Nachrichten, dann bist du weiter dran. So, Eiskasi, Peter.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt natürlich anfangen bei der Basistechnologie, nämlich SCSI. Das kennt sicherlich jeder oder SCSI, wie es manchmal heißt. Das ist eigentlich eine... Es hat mal angefangen als Parallelschnittstelle, die zwischen allen möglichen... Also fangen wir mal damit an, was es eigentlich heißt. Es heißt eigentlich Small Computer Systems Interface und wurde mal in den 80er Jahren etwa von der Firma Shugart entwickelt. Ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr in die Details gehen. Jedenfalls hat es angefangen als 8-Bit Parallelschnittstelle, ist dann immer breiter, immer schneller geworden. Und irgendwann hat man sich überlegt, weil das eine sehr intelligente Kommandostruktur hatte, oder Kommandostruktur ist das falsche Wort, also ein sehr intelligentes Protokoll gehabt hat, hat man sich überlegt, können wir dieses Protokoll nicht auf aktuelle Medien heben, und dann hat man das erst auf Glasfaser gesprochen, in solchen Storage Area Networks, und dann hat man irgendwann gesagt, na ja, unser Gigabit Ethernet ist ja eigentlich auch nicht viel langsamer als die Fiber, also können wir da doch auch über Gigabit Ethernet sprechen. Und so ist im Grunde genommen dieses GASI-Protokoll dann irgendwann auf einem Netzwerk gesprochen worden, und das hat man dann EISGASI genannt, das ist sozusagen...
Also eigentlich nur Hardware Abstraktionslayer.
Genau, das ist sozusagen SCSI über Internet, wenn man so will.
So, ihr habt es alle gehört. Bis zur nächsten Woche erwartet ihr dazu einen Kurzvortrag mit 20 Minuten Powerpoint-Präsentation. Wir machen gleich weiter am Chaosradio auf Fritz. Es geht heute um Datenträger, Datenverlust und Datenrettung. Das war ein kleiner Ausflug in die Grundlagen. Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten, danach geht es weiter hier auf Fritz. Eure Anrufe unter 0331 70 97 110.
Übrigens, man kann ja den Fritz Soundgarden von gestern Abend auch morgen Mittag hören. Oder man hört sich den Fritz Nightfly von vorgestern Nacht über morgen Morgen an. Oder man hört den Nightfly von vorvorgestern und den Fritz Soundgarden von heute Abend morgen Abend und über morgen Mittag und über über morgen Morgen. Wann und so oft man will. Es ist total leicht auf fritz.de. Soundgarden, Samaben und Nightflies. Also die Musik-Specials auf Fritz. Hört ihr wann und so oft ihr wollt. Im Fritz Loopstream. Geht einfach auf fritz.de und da dann links auf Streams und da sind sie. Die Fritz Loopstreams. Und das hört doch wann ihr wollt.
Zwei Minuten nach halb elf.
Nachricht. Mit Benjamin Eisel. Heute Abend wird sich vermutlich entscheiden, ob die Schüler am Berliner John Lennon Gymnasium im Winter eine Stunde später zum Unterricht kommen können oder nicht. Eltern und Lehrer sprechen gerade über den Vorschlag. Gestern und heute konnten die Schüler darüber abstimmen. Rausgekommen ist, dass die Mehrheit dagegen ist. Vor allem die jüngeren Schüler wollen, dass der Unterricht wie bisher um acht Uhr anfängt. Die Bundesregierung will mehr Geld für die Abwrackprämie ausgeben. Darauf haben sich Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und Vizekanzler Steinmeier geeinigt. Wie viel Geld zusätzlich bereitgestellt werden soll, steht noch nicht fest. Für die Abwrackprämie stehen bislang 1, 5 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Die Kfz-Branche geht davon aus, dass das Geld schon in den nächsten Wochen aufgebraucht sein wird. Im Kampf gegen die illegale Einwanderung werden die Bedingungen für die Einreise in die Europäische Union verschärft. Das hat das EU-Parlament in Straßburg beschlossen. In Zukunft muss jeder, der ein Einreisevisum beantragt, alle zehn Fingerabdrücke und ein biometrisches Foto abgeben. Dadurch soll es schwieriger werden, Visa zu fälschen. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Alba Berlin am Abend gegen Ulm gewonnen und damit seine Aufholjagd fortgesetzt. Das sind die aktuellen Temperaturen. Potsdam-Cockbus und Angermünde 2 Grad, Frankfurt-Wittenberger und Europin 3, in Berlin auch 3 Grad. In der Nacht gehen die Temperaturen auf bis zu minus 2 Grad runter. Dazu viele Wolken und besonders im Südwesten zeitweise etwas Regen oder Schnee. Morgen weiter stark bewölkt und gelegentlich kommt auch etwas Regen runter. Im Tagesverlauf soll aber auch wieder mal die Sonne rauskommen. Das Ganze bei 6 bis 9 Grad. Uns liegen keine Meldungen vor euch. Allen eine gute Fahrt.
Benjamin Eisel war das mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Es ist 5 Minuten, 4 Minuten nach halb 11. Und hier geht es gleich weiter im Chaosradio-Office.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Dann Fritz rund um Sprenberg.
Auf Fritz, Peter Frank ist bei uns, Starbuck ist bei uns, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, herzlich willkommen und Axel ist am Telefon. Hallo Axel.
Hallo nochmal.
Wir waren kurz unterbrochen durch die Information und du hattest noch eine Frage.
Ja, genau. Jetzt sehr viel kleiner. Ich betreibe selber auch so eine Art Mini-NAS.
Du betreibst ein was?
Ein Network Attached Storage, sprich ein Rechner, der eine Sammlung von Platten beinhaltet, die von überall aus dem Netzwerk aus gesehen werden können, damit man da seinen Daten drauf ablegen kann. Jetzt bin ich wieder mit der nächsten Abkürzung unterwegs, wird als Reit 5 betrieben. Müssen wir sicherlich auch noch drei Worte dazu sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das dann vielleicht besser könnt als ich. Im Endeffekt hat er eine Kapazität von zwei Terabyte. Die Frage ist, was wäre da für den Privatanwender eine sinnvolle Lösung, diese Daten nochmal zu sichern? Weil Bandlaufwerke für zwei Terabyte, also die das mit einem Band können, weil ich habe keine Lust, einen Bandroboter daneben zu stellen, die das mit einem Band können, sind abartig teuer.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, so ein Laufwerk kostet wahrscheinlich genauso viel wie das Nass, was du dahingestellt hast.
Wesentlich mehr.
Na dann ist die Antwort doch ganz leicht. Stell ein zweites daneben.
Weil irgendwie ist man in Größenordnung bei 1400 Euro oder so für so ein Bandlaufwerk.
Erklär uns doch mal, was du mit diesem Network Attached Story System bei dir zu Hause machst.
Ich war...
Außer Geld dafür ausgeben. Und dich ärgern, dass du die Daten nicht sichern kannst.
Geld dafür ausgeben ist das eine. Das Interesse am Basteln, das zweite. Und dann ging es einfach darum, ich sitze mal an dem Rechner und mal an dem und mal an dem. Und ärgere mich dann regelmäßig, dass ich genau das Bild, was ich jetzt suche, nicht auf dem Rechner zur Verfügung habe, sondern den CD-Stapel durchsuchen muss, wo das Bild, also das Foto, was ich irgendwann mal gemacht habe, von dem ich genau weiß, es war dann und dann und da und da, dass ich jetzt einen riesen Plattenstapel, CD-Stapel durchsuchen muss oder sage, ach Mist, das ist auf dem anderen Rechner oder das ist auf irgendwie einer externen Platte.
Damit du nicht immer mit USB-Sticks hinter deinem Ohren nicht die Genre entgegenbrennst.
Wenn du eine externe Platte hinterher hast, dann ist das eventuell ein Laptop, der bloß USB 1.1 kennt. Das rühre ich mir auf der Platte tot.
Jetzt haben wir verstanden, was du damit machst.
Und deine Filmsammlung ist doch bestimmt auch drauf, oder?
Filme habe ich so gut wie keine, weil ich mich immer noch ganz beständig dagegen weigere, Filme am Rechner zu gucken. Am Monitor gucken macht überhaupt keinen Spaß. Der ganze Aufwand in der Rechner ist dann laut und da muss man richtig aufantreiben. Ich habe einfach noch keinen vernünftigen Server, der das tut.
Das ist aber doch auch eine super Votung eigentlich für Network Attached Storage, weil diese ganzen, ich sag mal, diese Dreamboxen und diese Dinger, die man ja nun wirklich nicht am Bildschirm, sondern an einem totalen tollen Fernseher dran hat, die können sich das von da ja schon holen.
Mein Problem ist zurzeit, das gehört jetzt nicht ganz hierher, eine sinnvolle Lösung zusammen zu basteln, die DVB-C kann.
Ich bin sicher, das wird dir gelingen. Mir ist es nämlich auch schon gelungen.
Ja, die auch DVB-C kann und zumindestens den Schnickschnack, den Kabel Deutschland mir bei mir ins Kabel einspeist, dann auch dekodieren kann.
Na, ist ja noch, es ist nicht heute unser Thema.
Genau, aber ihr könnt euch ja gegenseitig Mails schicken und euch über eure Bastelerfolge informieren. Lass uns mal aber zurückkommen zum eigentlichen Thema.
Aber das geht schon. Aber die andere Frage, du hattest ja nun schon einige Fragen an uns, wir haben auch noch eine an dich. Nämlich hat es auf eurem HSM schon mal einen Datenverlust gegeben, denn auch selbst da, trotz dieser tollen Regundanz und so, kommt das gelegentlich vor?
So weit wie ich weiß nicht. Ich betreibe das Ding nicht. Ich bin nicht derjenige, der den Hut dafür aufhat. Also kann ich es nicht 100% ausschleißen.
Frag doch mal deine Admins. Das wäre schon mal interessant, weil es sind ja schon ein bisschen größere Daten und wichtige Daten.
Soweit wie ich weiß, ist es noch nicht passiert, an der Stelle zu müssen. An anderen Stellen schon, aber an der Stelle nicht.
Und bei dir zu Hause auch nicht, Amnas?
Das hab ich noch nicht so lange.
Aber wenn du für das nasse Backup willst, dann hör auf Peter, stell einfach ein zweites daneben.
Na, du kannst es natürlich auch. Ich sag jetzt mal, wenn das zwei Terra sind, kauf dir eine große Platte. Kaufe dir eine große USB. Na ja, Isata ist besser. Kaufe dir eine große Isata-Platte und steck sie dran.
Wahrscheinlich.
Also bei den Größen ist es irgendwie einfach eine einzelne Platte, die ihr dann in den Schrank legt, wahrscheinlich wirklich das Sinnvollste.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Sinnvollste, die man regelmäßig dransteckt und wieder drüber schreibt.
Oder du liest einfach mal wieder ein gutes Buch. Tschüss, schönen Abend noch. 0331 70 97 110 Wir machen hier heute nicht unbedingt Lebenshilfe für Nerds, aber trotzdem seid ihr eingeladen anzurufen und uns zu erzählen, wann ihr schon mal in den zweifelhaften Genuss eines Datenverlusts gekommen seid, eure Festplatte ist gecrashed, ihr hattet keinen Backup bzw. das Backup, was ihr habt, will nicht mehr dorthin zurück, wo ihr es braucht. Was macht man dann in so einem Fall? Das ist das Thema im heutigen Chaosradio. Datenträger, Datenverlust, Datenrettung. Peter Frank und Starbucks sind bei uns. Und der nächste am Telefon ist Martin. Guten Abend Martin. Tachchen, was ist dein Problem?
Und zwar hatte ich mehrere Hobbyprojekte auf einer Festplatte, ich speicherte ein paar Zeichnungen, ein paar Blenderwerte ein. Und irgendwann bin ich da mal hängen geblieben am Kabel und seitdem macht die Festplatte nur noch auf der Handy Geräusche. Und kann nicht mehr zugreifen. Liegt aber nicht an dem Festplatten in der Häuser, sondern an dem externen Häuser, weil ich hab da jetzt eine andere, alte 80 GB Festplatte drinnen und die funktioniert wunderbar.
Also am Kabel hängen geblieben, damit wolltest du uns durch die Blume sagen, dass die umgefallen ist oder runtergefallen ist?
Du hast auf der Platte jetzt Daten, die du gerne wieder hättest?
Ja, die sind jetzt schön und da hatte ich mich auch mal erkundigt. Im Internet gibt es ja so diverse Anbieter, die versprechen, ja, wir könnten eventuell Daten retten und welche Geräusche macht denn das? Die Festplatte und kostenlose Telefonnummer, bla. Habt ihr das schon mal?
Ja, da sind wir doch genau bei dem richtigen Thema schon.
Das ist genau das Thema. Martin, du bist quasi der perfekte Anrufer an diesem heutigen Abend.
Ja, naja gut, ich meine jetzt, na klar, da gibt es halt professionelle Datenretter und die können so was in Ordnung bringen. Und dieses Umfallen und das Geräusch sagt mir so, sagt mir aus meiner Erfahrung, dass da irgendwas zwischen die Köpfe liegen irgendwo mitten auf dem Medium, bis deine Spindel ist verbogen passiert ist. Da kommst du auf jeden Fall an einem Reihenraumlabor nicht vorbei.
Aus welcher Höhe ist sie denn gefallen, Martin?
Das ist leider auch eine sehr ungünstige Bewegung für so eine Festplatte. Also das Geräusch, was du so vorgemacht hast, das hört sich so an, als ob sich praktisch die Magnetscheiben da drin nicht mehr drehen. Sondern dass praktisch der Motorcontroller versucht, die in Drehung zu versetzen und das gelingt ihm nicht. Und dafür gibt es normalerweise zwei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Möglichkeit ist die sogenannte Stiction. Das heißt, dass die Köpfe auf den Oberflächen kleben. Und deswegen der Motor nicht genug Kraft hat, die Platte anzudrehen. Dafür muss man übrigens dankbar sein, dass er nicht genug Kraft hat. Der wird nämlich die Köpfe abreißen von ihren Trägern. Dann würden die Köpfe praktisch auf den Scheiben im Kreis fahren. Und das ist sicherlich nicht die normale Art, wie eine Platte funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollten wir vielleicht noch kurz erklären, wie Platten wirklich funktionieren im Einzelnen. Also man hatte wirklich rotierende Scheiben, wo halt irgendwie magnetische Medien drauf sind. Und halt einen Schreiblesekopf, der halt irgendwie in wirklich sehr kleinem Abstand ein paar Mikrometer.
Weniger.
Weniger als ein Mikrometer halt irgendwie auf dem Luftfilm gelagert über diese Platten bzw. die Platten drehen sich unter dem Kopf weg. Und dadurch werden dann halt ummagnetisiert oder beim Auslesen dann halt irgendwie die Magnete, also die Magnetspins ausgelesen. Und halt was bei dir passiert ist, ist halt durch das Umkippen ist der Kopf halt irgendwie auf die Platte raufgeschlagen, was halt normalerweise nicht passieren darf. Und dann halt irgendwie da dran festgeklebt oder was auch immer. Und das ist das Problem jetzt wohl.
Na wenn die Platte währenddessen in Betrieb war, dann kann man sogar davon ausgehen, dass die, dass die, also das ist ja im Prinzip, ist das eine Mechanik, das ist so eine Art, so eine Art Dorn. Also wir nennen das die Spindel, wo die, wo, wo diese Platten drauf gesetzt sind, mechanisch, das ist wie eine Art Achse. Also wie die Achse von einem, von einem Autorad.
Wie bei einem Schallplattenspieler kann man sich den ungefähr vorstellen.
Wenn diese Spindel verbogen ist, das heißt also durch dieses Umfallen, gerade diese Umfallbewegung ist ungeheuer gefährlich für die Spindel, die ist relativ dünn. Das ist so ein Stahlstift von, naja, sagen wir mal, ein paar Millimetern Durchmesser. Und das gesamte Plattengewicht lagert da drauf. Und wenn diese Platte jetzt umkippt, dann kann das eben tatsächlich sein, dass diese Spindel, und die ist ja auch gelagert noch, dass diese Spindel verbiegt und durch dieses Verbiegen praktisch dann die Lagerschalen an der Spindel praktisch zu einer Haftreibung führen, sprich das Ding dreht sich nicht mehr. Und das ist aber auch bei einer verbogenen Spindel sehr gut, denn da würde da drin alles kaputt gehen, wenn sich das noch drehen würde.
Also nehm Martin als glühendes Beispiel, macht mit euren Festplatten alles, klebt irgendwie Bussi-Bär-Aufkleber drauf, stellt sie auf eine Blumenvase, was auch immer, aber lasst die Dinger um Gottes Willen niemals umkippen oder fallen, dann habt ihr ein Problem. Was macht Martin jetzt aber mit der Platte? Du hast Datenrettung schon mal, professionelle Datenrettung schon.
Ich kann da sagen, also in dem Fall mit diesem Geräusch und dieser Geschichte kommst du an einem professionellen Rheinrahmenlabor nicht vorbei und da ist man auf jeden Fall immer bei so einem Problem schon mal mindestens ein paar Hunderter los.
Super, na dann scheiß ich da drauf und mach das nochmal neu. Aber ich hatte mal vor einer Weile sowas wie Flüssigkeiten gelagerte Festplatten gesehen.
Das sind eigentlich alle. Also alle modernen Festplatten werden heute mit sogenannten FTBs ausgeliefert, Fluid Dynamic Bearings. Das sind im Grunde genommen Flüssigkeitslager, die funktionieren so, dass zwei Platten einander gegenüber liegen, in die so kleine Gräben reingefriesst sind. Dazwischen ist eine Flüssigkeit, die Lagerflüssigkeit. Durch die Rotation wird sozusagen eine Welle dieser Flüssigkeit zwischen den Platten aufgebaut. Darauf schwimmt der gesamte Plattenstapel.
Also wenn man jetzt eine externe Festplatte hat? Also ich bin der Meinung, das Ding liegt da nicht so wirklich sicher.
Wirf sie doch einfach nicht um. Spiel damit die Tennis.
Ich bin nur immer am Kabel hängen geblieben. Die ist kurz hoch und wieder runter. Die war nicht an und nichts.
Wir machen es mal andersrum. Deine Geschichte lernt uns eine ganz wichtige Sache. Daten, die uns wirklich wichtig sind. Also die Dinge, die ihr für die Arbeit braucht. Private Erinnerungen, Fotos, Filme, was auch immer. Wenn ihr die auf einer Platte habt, ist das ganz gut und schön. Solltet ihr diese Festplatte beschließen, ins digitale Nirwana zu marschieren, habt ihr ein Problem. Also von solchen Sachen immer schön ein zweites Backup machen. Gerne auch auf eine DVD brennen oder so. Und den Schrank legen und dann sind sie auf jeden Fall erstmal sicher. Es sei denn der Schrank fällt dir um, aber dann hast du ein grob Motorikproblem, glaube ich.
Also das ist jedenfalls ein Problem, was du so selber nicht lösen kannst und da wird es leider auch für den privaten Geldbeutel teuer, wobei das eben auch relativ ist. Denn ich sag jetzt mal selbst ein paar tausend Euro sind im Vergleich zu einem Datenverlust von einem, sag ich jetzt mal, oder im Vergleich zum Zusperren eines ganzen Unternehmens eigentlich Peanuts.
Na, Navik willst du mal kurz erklären, was man dann halt machen würde in dem Reihenraum? Also wie man wirklich die Daten dann da runterkriegt?
Ja, das kann ich tun. Das ist eine gute Idee. Je nachdem welches Problem das hat, also ich denke mal, wenn wir mal mit dem einfacheren Problem anfangen, nämlich dass praktisch nur die Köpfe aus ihrer Parkposition und auf dem Medium stecken geblieben sind, dann kann man die Festplatte im Reihenraum zerlegen und kann mit speziellen Werkzeugen diese Köpfe von der Oberfläche abheben, ohne dabei die Oberfläche weiter zu beschädigen. Meistens hat die eh schon eine Schramme abbekommen. Weil der Kopf ja praktisch, wenn die Platte jetzt nicht gedreht hat, hat sie eben dieses Luftpolster, was Dabock ja vorhin schon erwähnt hat, hat sie nicht gehabt. Und das heißt, dass die Platte im Prinzip während des Kontakts mit dem Medium da reingeschrammt ist.
Also um bei dem Bild Schallplatte zu bleiben, du hast einen Kratzer in den Rillen. Und damit ist das Lied hin.
Ja, aber das muss eben noch nicht den Tod der Daten bedeuten. Also wie gesagt, wenn man im Rheinraumenlabor würde man so verfahren, man würde die Köpfe da rausholen, würde mit einem Satz neuer Köpfe dann das Medium auslesen. Das ist der einfachere Fall. Und muss natürlich dann noch auf diese Kratzer-Rücksicht gehen.
Wie macht man das? Fährt man da außen rum?
Also man kann um diese Kratzer, sag ich mal, bis zum gewissen Grad herum navigieren. Da will ich auch nicht zu tief ins Detail gehen. Ich meine, alleine über diesen Vorgang könnte ich euch mehrere abenden...
Okay, komm ich mal mit zwei praktischen Fragen, um den technischen Exkurs abzukürzen. Zum einen, wie lange lebt so eine durchschnittliche Festplatte?
Ja, das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann.
Und wann muss ich von meiner Platte, so wie Martin gerade, der Satzplatte ist tot, wann muss ich von meiner Platte ein zweites Backup machen, weil klar, solange macht's es nicht mehr.
Jederzeit, jederzeit. Man muss jeden Moment damit rechnen. Denn es ist, auch wenn es eine durchschnittliche Lebensdauer gibt, dann gibt es auch bei jedem Durchschnitt Extreme. Also ich hab in der Datenrettung Platten gehabt, die wurden von einem Antriebsriemen angetrieben. Die müssen so was um Mitte der 70er produziert worden sein und liefen noch bis letztes Jahr oder so etwas. Und die laufen da draußen auch immer noch. Und dann kann einem aber auch Dinge passieren, wie das ein Hersteller einen Fehler macht, wie kürzlich halt Seagate einen Fehler in der Firmware gemacht hat. Und so eine Platte meldet sich dann so nach dem, sagen wir mal, 50. Anschalten, sang und klanglos ab und ist weg.
Also niemals sicher sein, von den Wichtchensachen immer ein zweites Backup machen.
Ganz genau. Man kann es einfach nicht vorhersehen. Und auch diese ganzen Techniken, die vorgeben, das vorhersehen zu können, wie Smart, um mal das bekannteste Beispiel zu wählen, deren Aussagekraft ist nahe null.
Frage Nummer zwei, du hast gerade gesagt, es gibt für solche Fälle wie Martin professionelle Datenrettungsdienste. Das hört sich im ersten Moment ein bisschen an wie Schlüsseldienst. Gibt es da Kriterien, wer seriös ist und wer nicht? Weil ich gebe ja schon sehr persönliche Daten dann in fremde Hände.
Ich muss dazu sagen, da bin ich natürlich befangen, weil ich selbst in so einem Unternehmen arbeite. Und man sollte sich auf jeden Fall ein Bild über die Seriosität machen und sollte sich auch die Frage stellen, wer dahinter steht. Und unter Umständen sogar der Jurisdiktion, welches Landes die jeweilige Firma unterliegen würde. Da darf sich jeder selbst ein Bild machen. Also ich möchte hier keine Namen nennen, weil das irgendwie, das ist nicht...
Nee, aber es ist genau das, was ich hören wollte, dass du gesagt hast, guckt euch die Bruten vorher einen E-Roll-Platt dahin gebt. Martin, dann drücken wir dir die Daumen, dass du entweder deine Sachen noch mal sicherst oder beim nächsten Mal besser aufpasst mit dem Kabel.
Ja, klar.
Und der nächste am Telefon ist Robert. Er hat vorhin schon mal angerufen und ist jetzt wieder da. Hallo Robert.
Hallo ich bin.
Tachchen, was ist dein Problem?
Und zwar eigentlich das gleiche wie der Vorgänger, sag ich mal, wo es da zu Beginn eine Frage ist, ist ja recht teuer diese Datenrettung, richtig? Ja, und man sagte mir als Tipp, sag ich mal, am besten wir lassen die Platte im Schrank liegen und fragen in 10 Jahren nochmal nach, dann wird sie billiger.
Ist das eine Möglichkeit?
Es wäre denkbar. Allerdings nach meinen Erfahrungen ist es nach 10 Jahren eigentlich schon zu spät. Denn wenn ich heute eine Platte reinbekomme, die vor 10 Jahren aktuell ist, dann wird es meistens, naja gut, bei 10 Jahren vielleicht noch nicht. Aber ich hatte ja eben gerade das Beispiel erwähnt, dass ich eine aus den 70er Jahren hatte. Das ist sehr, sehr teuer geworden, weil ich die gesamte Technik dazu aufbauen musste. Das heißt, ich musste eine komplette Wachs aufbauen, ich musste den Plattenschrank dazu aufbauen, den Controller irgendwo hier beschaffen. Dann diese Platte wieder, also das war ja nur die HDA, also jetzt praktisch nur das Gehäuse mit den Scheiben drin, und das wieder in ein 19 Zoll Gehäuse einpflanzen. Und da war ein schöner großer Wechselstrommotor über einen Treibriemen mit verbunden.
Also das war nicht für 25, 30 Euro zu haben.
Und das alles wieder so zusammenzubauen, dass es im Grunde genommen, dass ich eine Anlage hab, die wie 1975 funktioniert. Und dann auch noch die darauf gespeicherten Formate in ein heute Lesbares zu übersetzen. Also du kannst dir vorstellen, das war nicht ganz preiswert. Ich denke mal, wenn du heute mit einer marktüblichen Platte ankommst, ist das dagegen ein Witz, was das kostet.
Also bleibt mir keine Möglichkeit, anstatt viel Geld auszugehen dafür, sag ich mal. Aber vom Liegen her geht es dir nicht kaputt, sag ich mal, oder?
Nein, also ich kann sowieso jedem, der ein Hardware-Problem an einer Festplatte hat, nur die Empfehlung, geben keinen Strom dran. Also Finger weg, Strom aus. Und dann kannst du sie im Prinzip fast beliebig lange liegen lassen.
Davon wird die praktisch nicht, die Daten gehen nicht verloren, und wenn sie liegt, dann liegt sie sozusagen.
Es sei denn, du bist wie Martin und spielst mit dem Ding noch ein bisschen Ice-Hockey auf dem Schleif. Das ist dann hässlich.
Nee, das natürlich nicht. Aber wie gesagt, mit Aufheben bringt es also auch nicht. Und wenn ein Künstchenanbieter selber könnte dir auch nicht sagen, oder wo das am besten zu machen ist, denke ich.
Es gibt halt Probleme mit den günstigen Anbietern. Es gibt durchaus sehr günstige Anbieter, nur sind deren Möglichkeiten natürlich auch begrenzt. Und je nachdem, was deine Platte hat, kannst du Glück haben, dass es hilft und du kannst Pech haben, dass es hinterher, dass es nicht hilft und es hinterher auch für einen weniger günstigen Anbieter dann keine Möglichkeit mehr gibt, das in Ordnung zu bringen. Das heißt, du musst dich halt wirklich fragen, sind das für mich wertvolle Daten? Und wenn, würde ich auf jeden Fall nicht den günstigsten Anbieter wählen. Also das ist eigentlich der Rat, den ich dir nur geben kann.
Kosten, Nutzen, Abschätzung, genau.
Also sagen wir mal, werben da einige mit kostenloser Analyse und ähnlichem und da kannst du dir ja überlegen, wie das Geschäftsmodell aussehen muss, damit sowas aufgeht.
Ja, ist richtig. Aber wie gesagt, man weiß nicht so eine Preisspanne, aber so Kosten sollte, sag mal. Ich hab mal Sachen gesehen für 300 und 600 Euro und da frag ich mich...
Nein, notwendig ist einfach, fünf verschiedene Anbieter angucken, die dir einen Kostenvoranschlag geben lassen, die gönnen dir in der Hausnummer sagen, was das kosten wird, dann kannst du immer noch abwägen.
Das Problem ist, leider Gottes, das Problem ist so, wie mit einem Kostenvoranschlag funktioniert das eben nicht, sondern das ist so, wenn du jetzt... Nehmen wir jetzt mal ein Beispiel aus dem richtigen Leben, mit einem Auto, dein Auto ist kaputt, es fährt nicht. Und jetzt rufst du fünf Werkstätten an und fragst sie, was kostet die Reparatur? Da kann dir keine dieser fünf Werkstätten eine seriöse Auskunft geben.
Ja, ist richtig.
Und mit Festplatten ist das irgendwie noch ein bisschen schwieriger, weil ich vorhin schon, ich hatte jetzt schon zwei Dinge erwähnt, die passieren können, wenn so eine Platte umkippt. Das ist auch noch stark abhängig vom Modell und von der Kapazität und vom Hersteller und was weiß ich, wie hoch der Aufwand dahinter wirklich ist. Und wenn jemand dir jetzt einen Festpreis macht, ich kann dir auch, du kannst mir den Festpreis, also ich sag jetzt mal, in unserem Labor kannst du diktieren, welchen Preis du bezahlen möchtest. Und dann gibst du mir sozusagen die Entscheidung in die Hand, ob ich das, ob das für mich, ab wann es für mich nicht mehr wirtschaftlich ist. Und das heißt, also wenn du jetzt sagst, meinetwegen, ich nenne jetzt einfach mal ein Beispiel, du sagst mir jetzt, du hast 500 Euro dafür ausgelobt und ich mach das Ding auf und sehe Spindel verbogen, klappe ich zu und schickse dir zurück und sag, kann ich nicht. Jaja klar, das ist ja halt eine Kalkulationsfrage, aber wenn solche Daten wirklich wichtig sind, dann ist die Sache ganz anders, dann sag ich jetzt mal, da muss man das, um überhaupt seriös was dazu sagen zu können, was das Ding denn nun hat, muss man sie eigentlich erst mal analysiert haben.
Also es ist ja so, dass halt einfach viele Probleme auftauchen können. Also es kann ja zum Beispiel auch einfach nur die Elektronik kaputt sein und dann irgendwie löhtet man irgendwie im Zweifelsfall irgendwie einen Stein aus, löhtet eine Ausstattung von der gleichen Festplatten-Serie den Stein wieder rauf und dann funktioniert sie auch wieder. Das heißt, irgendwie sie halt diesen Kosten vorensteigt, da muss man halt wirklich erst mal rauf geguckt haben.
Das wäre der günstigste Fall. Das klingt aber nach einem absolut krisensicheren Job. Was muss man eigentlich gelernt haben, um so einen Job zu machen, Peter?
Also ich denke mal, da muss so einen relativ guten Querschnitt durch fast alle Naturwissenschaften haben. Also auf jeden Fall ist es nützlich, wenn du Physik, Elektronik, Informatik und Mathematik kannst. Das ist auf jeden Fall von Vorteil.
Also morgen im Unterricht immer schön aufpassen. Robert, danke dir für den Anruf. Ich glaube, wir haben in ein Vespennest gestochen. Das heißt so schön, jetzt haben alle Leute irgendwie Probleme mit ihren Daten und ihren Festplatten. Veit klingt auch ganz dramatisch. Hallo Veit, guten Abend. Hey, du hast heute Daten durch ein Missgeschick verloren. Was ist denn passiert?
Ja, gestern oder so hat es angefangen, dass eine Platte rumordet oder sowas. Ich hab's ignoriert. Und heute Morgen kam dann so die E-Mail, dass mein Raid-Verbund gerade eben eine Platte verloren hat. Es sind zehn Platten drin gewesen, 640er Westin Digital. Und dann kommt bei dem E-Mail und ich so fuck, geh halt hin, guck welche Platte das ist anhand der SATA-Erkennungen, zieh die ab und dann geht halt dieses Geräusch aus. Und meine Freundin stand gerade hinten dran und ich so oh guck mal. Und wollte mir dir das Geräusch wieder zeigen und steck Strom wieder dran. Und bei dem gleichzeitig mal so pfff und alle Platten gehen aus.
Und der ganze Bildschirm voller Fehlermeldungen.
Dann hast du aber mal echt alles falsch gemacht, was man falsch machen konnte, oder?
Guck mal, der Grundsatz Nummer eins, den Peter eben schon angebracht hat, ist, wenn die Platte möglicherweise kaputt ist, lasst den Strom weg davon. Na ja, Veit, das weißt du jetzt auch. Okay, wie geht's weiter?
Ja, ich hab jetzt halt, eine andere Platte war irgendwie auch noch, hat Fehler gemacht und sowas. Also als ich es dann wieder angeschlossen hab und hab versucht, den Rate wiederherzustellen, hat er dann die Spare, die dann weg war, versucht, dann neu aufzubauen. Aber auf irgendeiner weiteren Platte waren dann plötzlich drei oder vier Sektoren defekt und dann hat er natürlich den komplett abgebrochen. Das war so ein Linux-Soft-Rate. Und ja, da hab ich quasi alles aufgegeben und hab halt jetzt dann neu aufgebaut, das 5TB an Filmen weg. Bisschen ärgerlich. Meine Frage wäre halt gewesen, mich noch ein bisschen zu ärgern, hätte man das eigentlich wieder herstellen können? Also hätte ich sagen können, hier ignorieren wir diese Scheißsektoren und dann hab ich halt irgendwie ein paar Dateien weg. Oder wär das sowieso aussichtslos gewesen?
Also mit ignorieren hätte man das sicherlich nicht wieder hinbekommen. Aber ich sag jetzt mal, das ist, dazu möchte ich zwei Anmerkungen machen. Die eine Anmerkung ist, das sind Standardfälle, die wir jeden Tag behandeln. Und die zweite Anmerkung ist, die Sicherheit, die Rät 5 suggeriert, kann es in vielen Fällen nicht einhalten. Und die meisten Rät 5 sterben beim Riebild. Und zwar gibt es dafür auch einen guten Grund. Genau, du bist im Grunde genommen, hast du den symptomatischen Problemfall des Rät 5 erlebt. Nämlich das, wo du eigentlich eine neue Platte reingesteckt hast, weil dir eine ausgefallen ist, dass genau in dem Moment eine andere Platte ausgefallen ist. Und die Wahrheit ist, die andere Platte hatte diese Leselfehler oder Fehler, welche Fehler auch immer, wahrscheinlich schon wesentlich länger. Es ist bloß nicht aufgefallen, weil das Rät grundsätzlich nur die Sektoren bewertet, die auch angefasst werden. Und wahrscheinlich wurden eben diese Fehler, diese Sektoren, die diese Fehler haben, längere Zeit nicht angefasst. Und deswegen ist das gar nicht aufgefallen, dass diese Platte schon ein Problem hatte. Nun ist es so, dass wenn du jetzt eine Spare-Platte reinsteckst und die soll rebuildet werden, das heißt, die soll aus den restlichen neun Platten bei dir, also wenn es zehn waren, muss die aus den restlichen neun berechnet werden. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass jeder Sektor auf jeder Festplatte in diesem Disk Array jetzt angefasst wird bei diesem Vorgang. Und das bedeutet, wenn es eben dort auf irgendeiner anderen Platte noch Probleme gibt, dass genau in dem Moment, wo dieses Rebuild durchgeführt wird, die Wahrscheinlichkeit am höchsten ist, dass dein Disk Array ausfällt. Und wenn das passiert, ist es natürlich klar, dass dein gesamtes Array hinüber ist. Weil, wenn an einer Stelle mehr als zwei Platten einen Fehler haben, dann kannst du die Daten nicht mehr berechnen bei RAID 5. Und dadurch sagt der RAID-Controller dann zurecht, das kann ich nicht mehr. Hier ist mal Schluss.
Also Veit, du hast sozusagen Domino-Stein mit Boxhandschuhen aufgebaut.
Aber die gute Nachricht ist, dass das für einen Seriösen Datenretter keine besonders große Herausforderung ist. Das heißt, man kann sowas in vernünftiger Zeit mit vernünftigen Kosten wiederherstellen.
Wie lange dauert sowas denn? Wenn du sagst vernünftige Zeit, was ist denn da die Größenordnung?
Na ja, so im Normalfall. Nein, bist du wahnsinnig.
Mach jetzt mal.
Also ich sag jetzt mal, der Standarddurchlauf für so einen Fall liegt zwischen zwei und vier Tagen. Und der Expressdurchlauf für seinen Fall, das waren glaube ich fünf Teraner, sagtest du fünf Terabyte? Okay, grob fünf Terabyte, zehn Festplatten, Rät fünf, Standarddurchlauf. Also zwei bis vier Tage und Expressdurchlaufzeit, würde ich mal sagen, kann, würde ich mal bei so was wie 48 Stunden, 24 bis 48 Stunden sagen.
Ist der Preis dann abhängig von der Anzahl der Platten?
Der Preis ist abhängig von der Anzahl der Platten, von der Schwere des Problems, von dem Gesamtvolumen der Daten. Also wie soll ich sagen, das ist ein Kaffeesatz-Algorithmus.
Veit, du siehst, es ist noch nicht alles verloren.
Jetzt habe ich also RAID 6 und neu aufgebaut.
Na ja, also es erhöht auf jeden Fall die Redundanz. Also es gibt ja mehrere Möglichkeiten, das anzugehen. Entweder man definiert mehrere RAID 5 Packs, sodass man im Zweifelsfall, sagen wir mal jetzt, du nimmst immer nur drei Platten oder vier Platten pro RAID 5 oder du hattest zehn, dann nimmst du halt fünf. Dann hast du halt zwei getrennte Arrays und dann verlierst du halt nur eins, wenn es schief geht. Die andere Möglichkeit ist halt RAID 6. RAID 6 verspricht dir eine höhere Redundanz. Ich vermute mal, dass du zwei Platten Redundanz genommen hast. Das heißt, du hast jetzt 8 plus 2, also Netto Kapazität von 8 Platten. Und da dürfen dir in der Theorie von 2 ausfallen und du hast immer noch alle Daten. Also das ist halt der Vorteil von RAID 6, dass du jetzt gegen den eben geschilderten Fall geschützt gewesen wirst damit.
Ich meine, dass es auch weiter laufen wird.
Aber man erkauft sich das bei RAID 6 natürlich mit sehr viel mehr. Also gerade, wie gesagt, das Linux Software RAID. RAID 6 braucht natürlich sehr, sehr viel mehr CPU-Lust. Denn RAID 5 muss nichts weiter tun, als eine XOR-Funktion auszuführen, während RAID 6 eben, naja gut, also die Algebra-Freunde unter uns, die können das grüne Buch rausholen. Da muss man, ich gehe jetzt auch nicht ins Detail, aber da muss dein Rechner schon erheblich mehr rechnen, um dort diese beiden Redundanzinformationen aufzubauen und besonders auch beim Auswirken derselben. Also wenn dir die zweite Platte weggeflogen ist, dann wird das auch signifikant langsamer, weil deine CPU richtig arbeiten muss.
Das hört sich so an, als ob Veit im Laufe dieser Woche und am Wochenende noch eine Menge Zeit vor seinem Rechner verbringen würde, um das alles in dessen Lauf zu kriegen. Veit, danke für den Anruf. Und zwar nicht irgendein Blue Moon, sondern das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Teil 144. Starbuck ist bei uns, Peter Frank ist bei uns, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Ihr seid herzlichst eingeladen in dieser Sendung teilzunehmen am Telefon unter 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute über Datenverlust und Datenrettung, hatten gerade eine Menge zu tun mit gecrasheden Festplatten, die nicht mehr das tun, was ihr eigentlich wolltet und der Frage, wie komme ich an meine Daten wieder ran. Aber es geht auch noch anders. Wir haben Dimitri am Telefon. Guten Abend Dimitri. Grüß dich. Bei dir geht es um Datenverlust bei CDs und DVDs.
Genau.
Und die möglicherweise immer wieder auftauchende Frage, stimmt das, dass CDs irgendwann mal an Qualität verlieren und dann nicht mehr das drauf ist, was ich irgendwann mal gekauft habe, oder?
Richtig und nicht mehr drauf ist, was ich da drauf gebrannt habe. Denn ich habe das Problem ab und zu mal gehabt, dass DVDs auf einmal nicht belesbar wurden. Und so hat sich nämlich die Datenschicht von der Plastikoberfläche des Datenträgers einfach zu gelöst.
Aber du hast nicht zufällig einen Aufkleber draufgetan?
Nee, die war eigentlich im Originalzustand.
Ja, es hat irgendwie unterschiedliche Qualitäten von so CDs und DVDs. Also ich hatte irgendwie auch so die ersten, als damals so die CDs irgendwie rauskamen, die man selber brennen konnte, dann wie die ersten paar Chargen, war das irgendwie so schlecht, dass man innerhalb von wenigen Monaten hat sich wirklich irgendwie alles abgeblättert. Wenn man die Sonne liegen lassen hat, für nur zwei, drei Stunden konnte man irgendwie durchgucken. Also es hat irgendwie wirklich ein ganz großes Qualitätsunterschied gehabt. Also dass halt wirklich Daten dadurch verloren gehen, dass halt irgendwie die Schicht sich dann einfach auflöst. Und so ist das bei dir dann wahrscheinlich auch gewesen, oder?
Genau, nur dass die CDs und DVDs von mir im Bankstieffach lagen, also komplett geschützt von der Sonne und von der Ostenwelt.
Na ja gut, das ist Feuchtigkeit ist auch noch ein Griffspunkt, also die Feuchtigkeit kriecht gerne zwischen den Polycarbonat Träger und die Lackschicht. Und gerade bei, sage ich jetzt mal, sehr günstig angebotenen, oder es hat noch nicht mal unbedingt was mit dem Preis zu tun, bei sehr günstig hergestellten, ist dieser Randabschluss häufig auch relativ schlecht, so dass die Feuchtigkeit dazwischen kann. Und dann hebt sich tatsächlich die obere Lackschicht samt der Aufzeichnungsschicht von dem Polycarbonat Träger ab. Und dann sind diese CDs oder DVDs mit herkömmlichen Methoden auf jeden Fall an der Stelle nicht mehr lesbar.
Was kann man denn da machen in so einem Fall? Also angenommen, ich hab eine DVD, wo lauter persönliche Briefe, Fotos und so was drauf sind, was mir extrem wichtig ist, meine Laufwerke zu Hause können das Ding nicht mehr lesen, dann geh ich wieder zum Datenretter.
Ja, dann hast du in dem Moment auch wieder keine andere Möglichkeit mehr, weil die ganze Konsumertechnik da auf solche Fälle nicht vorbereitet ist. Und auch die professionelle Technik ist auf solche Fälle nicht vorbereitet. Und eigentlich soll das ja auch nicht passieren. Aber wo jetzt Dava gerade sagte, oft in die Sonne legen, also davor kann ich nur inständig warnen, denn die Energie der Sonnenstrahlen ist also sehr nah an dem dran, was der Schreibleser von so einem Laufwerk tut. Und insofern, also bitte, bitte tut mir den Gefallen und bewahrt diese Dinger immer im Dunkeln auf.
Also die Kollegen, die auch CDs immer so im Auto einfach rumliegen haben.
Also Sonne ist wirklich der Tod, weil da eben auch sehr hoch energetische, kurzwellige Lichtstrahlen drin sind. Und besonders bei gebrannten Medien, da gibt es nämlich auch noch einen erheblichen Unterschied zwischen gebrannten und gepressten Medien, bei gepressten Medien, da wird ja im Grunde genommen ein Pressstempel in so ein Stück Alufolie reingedrückt. Und dieses Stück Alufolie ist natürlich wesentlich weniger empfindlich gegen Sonnenlicht als die Beschreibbaren. Bei den Beschreibbaren ist es ein sogenanntes Face-Change-Medium, was also sozusagen, was mit Hilfe eines Laserpulses zwischen der Amorphen- und Kristallinenphase hin und her geschaltet wird. Und da ist ja sozusagen, da ist gerade diese Lichtenergie dazu verwendet, um diese Phase umzuschalten. Und das bedeutet, dass man das natürlich da auch wieder rückgängig machen kann. Also gerade jetzt, jeder kennt ja auch wieder Beschreibbare Wesen. Und da muss es ja eine Möglichkeit geben, das auch umzukehren. Und da ist Sonnenstrahlung so was wie mit der Strohtflinte draufschießen.
Na, was würdest du denn für den Fall irgendwie jetzt tun, wenn du so eine DVD kriegst, die kaputt ist? Also die so abgeblättert ist oder wo sich die Schicht gelöst hat?
Also wenn die Schicht sich nur gelöst hat, ist das noch nicht der Tod. Wenn die Schicht komplett runter ist, dann würde ich sagen, dann ist das ein Fall, der sich nur noch lohnt, wenn das ein Staatsnotdatenträger ist. Also bei welchen wohl eine teilweise Ablösung oder Schrammen drauf sind, dafür haben wir Maschinen, mit denen wir die noch rotierend auslesen können. Sobald man sie sozusagen nicht mehr rotieren kann und sie rotierend auslesen, wird die Sache schnell sehr, sehr teuer.
Also ihr lest sie dann praktisch auf dem gleichen Weg aus, wie ein Player das auch machen würde, aber irgendwie die ganze Fehlerkorrektur macht ihr dann selber, oder?
Genau. Das ist die eine Methode und die andere Methode ist dann halt die mit der optischen Mikroskopie. Und da gibt es auch einige, kann man auch im Netz einige Forschungsarbeiten dazu finden. Da wird dann eben sehr langsam rotiert und wird quasi im Grunde genommen, in der Kamera werden kleine Stückchen von der Scheibe dann geknitzt. Und diese Bilder setzt man dann zusammen an der Stelle, wo sie zusammen gehören. Also die Probleme möge sich jeder selber ausmalen. Und dann muss man eben den sogenannten Read Channel, also sozusagen die Logik, die eigentlich aus den Pits und Lans hinten raus Userdaten macht, dann aus diesem Bild, praktisch durch einen Querschnitt durch das Bild, muss man eigentlich dieses Readback Signal simulieren und muss das dann durch einen simulierten Read Channel durchschieben und dann durch die simulierte Fehlerkorrektur hinten durchschieben und dann kommen mit viel Glück hinten Userdaten raus, aber das eben mit einer Bitrate, die, sag ich jetzt mal, im kommerziellen Bereich nicht sinnvoll ist.
Also das klingt ja schon so, als wenn optische Medien deutlich problematischer wären als magnetische zum Wiederherstellen.
Nein, das stimmt so auch nicht. Denn bei den magnetischen habe ich halt das Problem, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise, es gibt ja so, die Substrate von diesen Festplatten sind zum Teil Glas und zum Teil Aluminium. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel eine Glasplatte habe und die es gesplittert und ich habe nur noch eine Scherbe von der Festplatte, dann wird das auch sehr schnell sehr aufwendig. Dann muss ich im Grunde genommen das gleiche Verfahren anwenden, aber dann mit raster Sondenmikroskopie. Und das ist noch ein bisschen aufwendiger, als wenn man es, sage ich jetzt mal, mit einem hochvergrößernden Mikroskop.
Schaffen wir nicht in zwei Tagen.
Dimitri, jetzt hast du gehört, wie es geht. Viel Spaß beim Nachbauen. Alles Gute mit der Hobby-Tek von Fritz.
Eben gerade war das Thema RAID 5 bei euch.
Ich das von mir eigentlich auf RAID Z, von ZFS.
Also, besser oder schlechter?
Wähle zwischen zwei Gulen.
Das kann ich verstehen, aber ich sag's mal so. Wenn ich da irgendwie ein Problem mit zwei Datenträgern hätte, würde ich das ganze RAID verlieren? Oder könnte ich einfach sagen, Rebuild mir wirklich das, was du machen kannst und dass es eben weg ist, ist eben weg.
Also im Regelfall verliert man alles beim Ausfall von zwei Datenträgern bei RAID 5. Aber das ist halt, wenn du immer, wenn du die vorgesehene Redundanz, also wenn du mehr verloren hast als die vorgesehene Redundanz, ist im Regelfall dein Datenbestand hinüber. Und davor kann dich auch ZFS nicht schützen. Denn auch wenn ZFS die Redundanz nicht mehr hat, man kann es eben nur noch so lange berechnen, solange man noch genügend Information hat, aus der man es berechnen kann.
Alles klar, dann viel Spaß beim Nachbauen, Dimitri.
Bis denn, ciao.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, ihr merkt schon, es geht um Datenrettung, um Datenverlust und Datenträger und auch die Frage, wie kriege ich die Daten, die ich auf meinen Festplatten habe oder auf irgendwelchen Speichermedien, die mir wichtig sind, wie kriege ich die so sicher, dass die mir nicht irgendwann um die Ohren fliegen und dann plötzlich nicht mehr da sind. Ein paar Tipps hatten wir schon. Es fängt an bei so grundsätzlich kleinen Sachen. Bitte niemals am Kabel der Festplatte ziehen. Wenn die Festplatte rotiert, wenn das Ding umfällt, wird es nämlich hässlich. Legt eure CD's nicht in die Sonne, weil Sonnenlicht ist wie mit einer Schrotflinte da draufschießen. Und noch andere Sachen. Wir haben noch eine Wortmeldung von Björn. Guten Abend, Björn. Moin, von wo rufst du an?
Aus Hannover ruf ich an, meiner Kleinstadt daneben.
Aus Expo City Hannover?
Ja, ein bisschen nah dran, aber passt schon.
Alles klar, dein Computer war nicht nett zu dir?
Jo, das ist schon ein bisschen länger her. Das stammt aus der Zeit, wo 200 GB Festplatten noch richtig groß waren. Und zu dieser Zeit, wo 200 GB Festplatten noch richtig groß waren, konnte Windows XP ohne Service Pack 1 die noch nicht unterstützen. Da ging es nur bis zu 137 GB. Jo, und dann hab ich mein tolles Windows neu installiert auf der 80 GB Festplatte, die noch in dem Rechner war. Und nachdem die Installation dann vollendet war, nach dem ersten Start von Windows, fing Windows an die zwei Partitionen, die ich auf der 250 GB Festplatte hatte, zu reparieren.
Das klingt scheiße.
Ja, und das reparierte er dann so genial, dass ich, wenn ich ein Video von der einen Partition anklickte, eine MP3 von der anderen Partition hatte.
Ey, aber das ist immerhin ein kreativer Auswahl.
Das hätte ich Microsoft gar nicht zugetraut.
Guter Zufall, es geht dann auf 2.0.
Ich hab auch noch eine kreative MP3 aus dem Ausfall. Das ist ein Song von Nick Case. Da wird mittendrin einfach mal 3 Minuten lang Black Metal gespielt. Ich hatte dann halt verschiedene Shareware Festdatenrettungsprogramme durchlaufen lassen, die immer so 5 Stunden brauchten. Hab meine Schlafrhythmen dann immer drauf abgestellt, dass ich diese Zeit dann schlafe. Bin dann aufgestanden, hab gesehen, dass nichts gebracht hat. Hat das nächste Tools versucht, bin wieder zum Schlafen. Und das, was mich dann gerettet hat, war nach 5 Tagen der zweite Versuch mit Knoppix. Das konnte dann wieder lesen, war aber zu der Zeit, als Knoppix noch nicht USB 1.1 unterstützte und ich die Festplatten, den Inhalter irgendwo hin kopieren musste über USB, was auch ein Trick war, weil ich musste erst mal die 200 Gigabyte, das war damals viel, zusammen sammeln über Freunde, Bekannte und so weiter und so fort. Und das hat dann auch nochmal gut 2 Tage in Anspruch genommen, diese Dinge über USB 1.1 auf externe Festplatten zu kopieren.
Und ist diese Black Metal Einlage dabei wieder los geworden oder ist die dabei geblieben?
Nein, die MP3 hab ich heute noch auf der Platte.
Björn, was hast du daraus für das Jahr 2009 gelernt?
Kein Windows mehr.
Ist doch auch eine Ansage. Danke für den Anruf.
Jo, kein Problem.
Chaosradio auf Fritz 0331 70 97 110. Peter hat schon ein bisschen erzählt, wie Datenrettung im Detail funktioniert, wie das in den professionellen Datenrettungsfirmen läuft. Wir haben Christian am Telefon, der so ein ähnliches Problem anspricht. Hallo, Christian. Du hast...
Ja, ich habe ein Problem. Also ich bin auch immer der Ansprechpartner für Computerprobleme in meinem ganzen Bekanntenkreis. So, jetzt habe ich eine USB-Festplatte hier. Also was sie damit genau gemacht haben, das haben sie mir nicht gesagt. Ich gehe mal davon aus, sie haben sie während dem Betrieb runtergeschmissen. Also ich nehme es mal an. So, das war in USA, da sind Urlaubsbilder drauf. So, es ist so, die wären auch bereit, für eine Datenrettung was zu bezahlen. Also das Geld ist da mal sekundär. Jetzt haben die das beim Datenretter gehabt. Ich sage mal nicht den Namen, weil das darf mich hier wohl nicht sagen. Jetzt haben die da eine Mappe bekommen, mit Werbung drin, keine Ahnung, bla bla. Es steht hier ein Zettel dabei, steht irgendwie ganz klein drauf. Auf jeden Fall sowas Ähnliches. Media Damaged, Repairing Possible oder sowas Ähnliches. Also diese Datenretter in den USA war der Meinung, man kann das nicht mehr retten, und haben es denen wieder mitgekriegt. Die haben sie wohl auch aufgemacht. Das sieht man wohl. Meine Frage ist, kann man überhaupt noch irgendwas machen, oder kann ich es jetzt vergessen?
Also man kann dazu eigentlich sagen, man kann immer irgendwas machen. Das ist nur eine Frage des Preises. Es ist nur eine Frage, wie viel man dafür ausgeben will und wie lange man darauf warten muss. Das ist sozusagen mal die allgemeine Antwort. Die praktischere Antwort ist, dass mit jedem Eingriff im Regelfall das Problem schlimmer wird. Das heißt, man muss auf jeden Fall beim ersten Mal den, es ist das Beste, man erwischt beim ersten Mal den richtigen Datenretter, da eben, sag ich jetzt mal, solche Eingriffe die Platte weiter beschädigen können. Ich hab die Platte nicht gesehen und kann deswegen nicht sagen, ob das jetzt, kann das jetzt aus der Ferne nicht beurteilen, aber wenn ich ihnen raten sollte, würde ich sagen, sie können sich an einen weiteren Datenretter wenden und sie können dem am besten auch gleich sagen, wer da vorher die Finger drin gehabt hat. Die können sich natürlich alle untereinander auch. Und dann kann der ihnen eigentlich eine relativ gute Schätzung sagen, ob es noch einen Sinn hat da nochmal reinzuschauen.
Ich hab mal angerufen, bei einer Firma nennen wir sie mal Abzock, hab ich ihm angerufen und dann hat der gesagt, ja, Köpfe tauschen kann man gar nicht. Und das ist alles nur Humbug und die können die eh noch anschließen, mit dem Programm irgendwas durchgucken.
Also da haben sie offensichtlich eine unqualifizierte Firma erwischt.
Ja, ich sage ja, der Name Abzock steht dann wohl auch Programm. Also das heißt, man kann da auf jeden Fall was machen.
Natürlich, natürlich und ich hatte ja eben schon das Beispiel von der Scherbe eines Mediums mal erwähnt. Das ist im kommerziellen Bereich nicht sinnvoll, aber es gibt durchaus Kunden, die bereit sind, sehr viel Zeit und sehr viel Geld zu investieren, um herauszufinden, was auf dieser Scherbe denn gestanden hat. Und auch das ist machbar. Es ist eben nur nicht in einem, in ihrem Fall sind diese Methoden aus meiner Sicht wirtschaftlich nicht sinnvoll.
Na gut, Zeit spielt hier keine Rolle. Mir geht es nur darum, ist es sinnvoll, sich nochmal an jemanden zu wenden?
Auf jeden Fall würde ich sagen, ja, wenn Ihnen die Daten lieb sind, sollten Sie sich an einen seriösen Datenretter wenden und vielleicht auch nochmal die meistens irgendwas zwischen ein und 200 Euro für eine Diagnose investieren. Dann kriegen Sie auf jeden Fall, sag ich jetzt mal, kriegen Sie auf jeden Fall im Regelfall eine qualifizierte Antwort, was mit Ihrem Datenträger los ist und wo auch genau drin steht, was das Problem ist und wo auch genau drin steht, welche Methoden man anwenden müsste, um dieses Problem zu lösen und wo das dann auch mit den entsprechenden konkreten Preisen belegt ist.
Und wenn das alles nicht funktioniert, Christian, haben Sie immerhin noch die Legitimation, einen neuen Urlaub dran zu hängen, um neue Urlaubsvodos zu machen?
Und gut, wenn die Mädchen sein Freunde für die Zeit leiten, dann kann ich das machen.
Alles klar. Das klärt ihr untereinander. Danke dir für die Ahnung. Tschüss, Christian. Wir haben jetzt ganz viel über Festplatten gesprochen, über auch CDs, DVDs, also alles, was so rotiert, was irgendwie mit Schreib- und Lesegeräten funktioniert. Volker ist am Telefon. Der hat was zum Thema Flash-Speicher, was ja dann nicht so einfach geht. Hallo, Volker.
Ja, beziehungsweise Festplatte funktioniert auch, wenn die Festplatte mechanisch in Ordnung ist. Häufig genug hat man ja das Problem, dass die Daten dann auf dem Fallsystem im Eimer sind, weil das Dateisystem vollgelaufen ist, weil die Kamera ein etwas anderes Verständnis vom Fahrtfallsystem hat als der Datenspeicher oder ähnliches. Und dann ist halt mal der Speicher kaputt, lassen sich Fotos nicht auslesen oder sowas.
Na der Speicher ist ja nicht kaputt, also die Daten sind ja noch drauf.
Genau da setzen dann die entsprechenden Tools an, aber zumindest legt man in den Computer ein, die Fotokarte oder die Platte hängt man per USB dran und kann sie erstmal so nicht lesen.
Es gibt ja grundsätzlich zwei mögliche Arten von Schäden. Wir unterscheiden die immer in die zwei Klassen physikalischer Schaden und logischer Schaden. Genau und der Logische, der ist natürlich klar, dass es gibt eben auch Schäden, die durch wild laufende Betriebssysteme oder das Abziehen der Betriebsspannung im falschen Moment oder ähnliches entstehen können, sodass eben die Dateisysteme oder überhaupt die Verwaltungsstrukturen, die uns sagen, welcher Name denn zu welchen Sektoren welche Datei ergibt, dadurch in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden können. Diese ganzen Probleme, die fassen wir zusammen unter logische Probleme, weil dort ja im Grunde genommen der Datenträger keinen technischen Defekt hat. Ich kann jeden Sektor des Datenträgers lesen, aber mein Betriebssystem oder mein Dateisystemtreiber kann daraus nicht mehr die ursprüngliche Struktur wiederherstellen.
Genau. Ich bin jetzt da teilweise im Forensikbereich aktiv. Was dann gemacht werden sollte, ist, nicht mit einem normalen Tool ranzugehen, also ich, Photoreq, Free Andelete, Andelete, irgendwelche Rescue Tools, da die meistens sofort wieder auf dem Ding rumschreiben. Das heißt, wenn die sich vertun, dann sind die Daten meistens noch besser durcheinander gewürfelt.
Wenn du sagst, du beschäftigst dich mit Forensik, dann wolltest du wahrscheinlich vorschlagen, dass man erstmal eine Imagekopie davon machen will.
Genau.
Diesen Vorschlag möchte ich mich gerne anschließen. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Überhaupt generell, wenn man jetzt so einen Datenverlust hat und man ist sich vielleicht nicht ganz sicher, ist es denn ein technisches Problem am Datenträger oder ist es ein logisches Problem, denn das ist manchmal gar nicht so leicht auseinanderzuhalten. Man stellt nur fest, das Betriebssystem zeigt dieses oder jenes Verzeichnis nicht mehr an. Das kann beide Ursachen haben. Dieser Rat ist sehr gut. Machen Sie eine Imagekopie von der Platte und wenn das an irgendeiner Stelle abbricht mit einer obskuren Fehlermeldung oder so etwas, dann gilt Regel Nummer zwei, Stecker raus, Finger weg.
wenn sich bei Festplatten entsprechend Geräusche melden.
Das hatten wir das hier vorhin schon gehabt. Wenn Geräusche sind wirklich irgendwie nichts, dann irgendwie ja, ich lass das mal noch zwei, drei Tage laufen.
Der Glaube an die technische Selbstheilung. Morgen wird's schon wieder gehen.
Dann ist die Kacke schon an Dampfen. Dann hat wirklich sofort Datenrettung einleitet, weil irgendwie jede Minute zählt dann.
Genau, jede Umdrehung kann mehr Späne produzieren.
Es gibt dann einmal die einfachen Tools, die Daten, die gelöscht sind oder nur teilüberschrieben sind, zumindest im Direktor verteilt überschrieben sind, wiederhergestellt werden können. Es gibt dann auch die etwas gründlicheren, die einfach dann nach entsprechenden Headern von Fotos, von typischen Office-Dokumenten suchen und dann versuchen von dort aus einfach die anschließenden Dateiblöcke bis zu einem sieht nach einem Ende aus wiederherzustellen.
Wobei ich dazu sagen muss, wenn man kein professioneller Datenretter ist, dann kriegt man viele Dateien, von denen nur ein paar funktionieren. Dann kann ich generell nur vor dem Einsatz von Tools warnen, es sei denn, dass die Daten nicht so wichtig sind. Es gibt ja auch so Sachen, wo man sich sagt, naja, wenn es weg ist, ist es auch nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt probiere ich nochmal. Dann kann man natürlich alles damit machen. Das ist keine Frage. Aber wenn es sich wirklich um unternehmenskritische Daten handelt, dann würde ich auch abraten überhaupt von irgendeinem Tool-Einsatz. Weil nämlich, selbst wir brauchen sehr lange, um herauszufinden, was diese kommerziellen Tools genau tun. Und ich sage einfach mal, dass der durchschnittliche Anwender das mitnichten überblicken kann. Ganz genau. Das ist auch eine Grundregel. Aber selbst bei den Imaging-Tools, da wird schon problematisch. Ich meine, jetzt viele Anwender sind auch aus meiner Sicht nicht in der Lage, ein 1 zu 1 Image von einer Festplatte herzustellen. Und auch da kann man eben Fehler machen. Da kann man auch beispielsweise Quelle und Ziel verwechseln. Und dann hat man seinen Datenträger mit Nullen überschrieben. Also man muss auf jeden Fall, wenn das wirklich was wert ist, dann soll man es den Profis überlassen. Und ansonsten, wenn man meint, es ist nicht so dramatisch wertvoll, dass man es selber probieren möchte, dann sollte man auf jeden Fall sehr viel Sorgfalt walten lassen beim Einsatz. Geht weder Tools und immer nur auf Kopien arbeiten.
Beziehungsweise...
Das ist ein guter Ratschlag.
Beziehungsweise, wenn ihr ein Tool habt, was irgendwie hier kostet nichts, probiert mal aus, kostenlose Download-Version, tralala, dann probiert das wirklich erst mal aus an irgendwas, wie Peter schon richtig gesagt hat, was wenn es dann weg ist, okay, nicht so dramatisch, aber nicht einfach irgendwo dran rumdoktern. Im Zweifelsfall macht ihr es nicht besser. Volker, danke für den Anruf.
Die Notschaft, die Volker gebracht hat, die war schon sehr richtig und wichtig, dass man ja, wenn der Datenträger nicht beschädigt ist, eigentlich immer eine hundertprozentige Kopie davon herstellen kann. Und das sollte man auch tun. Und auf dieser, also auf dieser sozusagen Tochterkopie kann ich ja drauf rumpferwerken, so viel ich will, ohne jetzt das Original zu beschädigen. Insofern ist das war das absolut der korrekte Hinweis.
Auf dem Image.
Ja.
Was sind denn physikalische Schäden an Flash-Speichern?
Physikalische Schäden an Flash-Speichern sind beispielsweise, wenn Flash-Zellen ausgefallen sind oder was auch häufig passiert ist, dass die Controller sich verirren, dass die halt also praktisch ihr Wear-Management aus dem Ruder läuft und dass sie selber nicht mehr wissen, wo sie die Sektoren hingetan haben. Und dass sie dann einfach sich praktisch totstellen, weil sie nicht mehr, weil sie die Zuordnung zwischen der Sektoradresse, die du dem Sektor gegeben hast und der Sektoradresse, die es tatsächlich in dem Speicherchip hat, nicht mehr wieder hinbekommen.
Kann man das dann nachträglich wieder rausfinden? Also wie rekonstruiert man die Daten dann?
Also wir machen das dann so, dass wir die Ships da einzeln rausholen, die dann auslesen, dann in eine Datenbank rein tun, also praktisch den Inhalt der einzelnen Ships. Und dann aufgrund der Kenntnisse, wie diese Controller arbeiten, die halt im Wesentlichen reverse-ingeniert sind. Wo man Glück hat, sind sie aus Datenblättern, wo man Pech hat, sind sie reverse-ingeniert. Und dann praktisch diese Zuordnung wieder aufbauen mit Hilfe von unseren eigenen Tools.
Wir sehen, Datenrettung ist ein weites Feld, was viele von euch auch interessiert. Hier die Leitungen sind knackervoll. Ich fürchte jetzt sogar schon um kurz vor halb zwölf, dass wir nicht alle rankriegen werden. Tim ist der nächste am Telefon, der ein Problem hat, was wir möglicherweise schon besprochen haben. Deswegen geht es eventuell schnell. Hallo Tim, guten Abend.
Ja, also ich hab eigentlich zwei Festplatten bei mir schon eine gewisse Zeit rumliegen. Das eine ist eine IBM Festplatte, da hatte ich schon mal im Internet nachgesehen. Das soll früher wohl ein Problemkind gewesen sein. Die Festplatte soll wohl dafür bekannt sein, dass die mehrmals den Geist aufgegeben hat. Das da, ja ich kann den Typ ja jetzt nicht sehen.
Na, steht ja drauf.
Na ja, hier steht so viel drauf.
DTLA 3040, irgendwas steht da. Genau, Modell.
EC 35L 120.
Ja genau, das ist der Nachfolger von der Platte.
Also die soll dafür worden sein.
Ich hatte die zwar immer mal so aufgemacht, also jetzt nicht richtig in die Innereien. Ich sage mal nur so, wo man in die Elektrik rankommt. Und dann hat es immer mal wieder so funktioniert, aber dann hat es irgendwann halt nicht mehr funktioniert.
Hast du denn deine Daten noch runtergekriegt, bevor es nicht mehr funktioniert hat?
Und die sind dir extrem wichtig?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, die auf der zweiten Festplatte, das ist eine Samsung, die sind mir wichtiger, weil da sind die ganzen Fotos drauf von der Geburt meiner Kinder.
Das ist schwieriger als beim Urlaub, nicht? Geburten von Kindern sind schwieriger zu reproduzieren.
Deswegen, also, das ist natürlich sehr wichtig. Vor allen Dingen, wenn ich die nicht irgendwie noch runterkriege, kriege Chaos von meiner Frau.
Was wir alles nicht wollen.
Also bei der Samsung war das Problem, ich hatte dort hauptsächlich TrueCrypt-Container benutzt. Und komischerweise haben da ein, zwei Container als erstes den Geist aufgegeben, die konnten nicht mehr verbunden werden. Nein, das ist nicht korrekt. Die wurden verbunden, aber es konnte nicht auf die Daten zugegriffen werden. Ich hab also immer bei der Verbindung, die lief ganz normal über TrueCrypt, aber wenn ich auf die Daten zugreifen wollte, wurde mir eine Fehlermeldung ausgegeben. Und dann irgendwann hat die gesamte Festplatte den Geist aufgegeben.
Das hört sich auch wirklich nach einem physikalischen Problem an. Es hört sich nicht so an, als ob deine Crypto-Container da beschädigt sind, sondern wahrscheinlich hatte die Platte schon Lesefehler und darüber hat sich das TrueCrypt beschwert, weil es bestimmte Sektoren nicht mehr entschlüsseln konnte. Und ich fürchte, da bist du jetzt auch ein Fall für einen professionellen Datenretter geworden. Also sollte sowas mal wieder passieren, würde ich versuchen, die TrueCrypt-Container auf einen anderen Datenträger zu gucken.
Also was mich jetzt so ein bisschen verwirrt, ich hatte mir auch so Tools runtergeladen, ich weiß nicht was alles, unter anderem dann hier auch die System Rescue CD, was ja hier so eine Linux Live CD im Grunde eigentlich ist. Jetzt will ich mir das Programm nicht mehr einfallen, was auf Linux basiert, ist relativ bekannt, aber für Datenrettung.
Wahrscheinlich meinst du DD Rescue, also für den Kopierteil des Images, oder?
Naja, gut, auf jeden Fall werden mir da die Daten angezeigt und der rödelt auch los. Und er meldet mir, er hat das repariert, aber das Problem bleibt dasselbe wie vorher, nämlich dass ich auf die Festplatte nicht zugreifen kann.
Also repariert klingt schon mal ausgesprochen fischig, muss ich sagen. In dem Zusammenhang eine kaputte Festplatte per Software reparieren, das ist mir noch nie gelungen.
Dass die Daten wieder hergestellt sind.
Machen wir wirklich erstmal eine Kopie von der Platte, was wir schon öfter gesagt haben. DDoSQ zum Beispiel macht wirklich ein komplettes Image. Auf dem Image kannst du erstmal weitergucken, mit anderen Tools drauf rumspielen, weil da kann man auch nichts mehr kaputt machen. Man kann eben durch die Kopie immer wieder einspielen.
Das Problem ist, man kann durch das Kopieren auch noch mehr kaputt machen. Wenn es wirklich zu einem Familienstreit führt, würde ich mich doch lieber mal an einen Datenretter wenden. Und würde dann auch wirklich die Platte nicht mehr unter Strom setzen. Denn das, was du so erzählt hast, das hört sich eindeutig danach an, dass die Platte einen technischen Defekt hat. Und ich würde sogar mal aus der Hüfte geschossen sagen, einen Oberflächendefekt. Und der wird halt mit jeder Umdrehung der Platte schlimmer. Und den kannst du auch nicht beheben. Und auch nicht mit den Linux Voodoo Utilities. Denn das ist einfach ein Problem. Das ist wie wenn du mit der Zieglinge über die Schallplatte gefahren bist. Das kann man mit Software nicht in Ordnung bringen.
Genau, also mechanisches Problem, Hardwareproblem, nicht mit Software zu lösen.
Gut, aber vielleicht noch eine abschließende Frage. Wird vielleicht auch anderen interessieren. Es wird ja jetzt immer viel mit Extans, das Festplatten gearbeitet, die dann halt nur über USB angeschlossen sind. Ich hab jetzt auch einen Notebook. Das heißt also meine Rettungsversuche habe ich alle über USB Anschluss gemacht. Gibt es da Unterschiede? Geht das mit USB teilweise vielleicht überhaupt nicht?
Na ja, USB hat eigentlich nur einen einzigen Nachteil, nämlich, dass es schrecklich lahm ist. Also wann immer man USB durch eSata ersetzen kann, sollte man das tun. Weil USB ist einfach nur furchtbar lahm.
Also ansonsten hast du natürlich da auch einen ganz normalen IDE oder Sata-Controller in dem externen Gehäuse drin und irgendwie einen Umsetzer auf USB. Also sonst irgendwie eigentlich das Gleiche. Und im Zweifel kannst du halt immer die Platte aus dem Rahmen ausbauen und dann einen Desktop-Rechner einbauen und dann hast du irgendwie so wie es vorher.
Na gut, bei den aktuellen Konsumeprodukten kriegt man die Gehäuse kaum zerstörungsfrei auseinander. Es sei denn, man ist ein Meister des Plectrums.
Nee, also ich hab mir das immer selbst zusammengestellt. Das heißt, ich hab mir eine normale Einbaufestplatte geholt und dann extern die Gehäuse.
Also ich schwöre bei externen Gehäusen im Moment total auf ihr Saat da, weil das halt die gleiche Geschwindigkeit bringt wie eine interne Platte und ich trotzdem noch den Vorteil hab, dass ich die Platte separat vom Rechner habe.
Aber das USB-Netz, dass ich das nicht selber reparieren konnte wegen USB-Anschluss ist nicht möglich.
Das hat damit eigentlich nichts zu tun. Also ob du die Platte nun über Skasi oder über USB oder Buschtrommel anschließt, das macht doch keinen Unterschied.
Und im Zuge des allgemeinen Familienfriedens, wir wollen ja nicht, dass deine Frau dich vertrimmt. Sieh zu, dass die Platte bei Leuten in die Hände kommt, die wissen, was sie damit tun. Und befolge den Rat von Peter Frank. Lass den Strom von dem Ding, ja? Tschüss Tim. Nachrichten Wetterverkehr kommen gleich hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz und danach geht es weiter unter 0331 70 97 110.
Sie kommt für alle Fritz Freunde und deren Freunde. Und sie wird größer als alles bisher Dagewesene. So groß, dass man sie sogar vom Mond aus sehen könnte. Wenn er nicht so weit weg wäre. Und das hört man.
2, 5, 12.
Nachrichten.
Mit Benjamin Eüssel.
Am John Lennon Gymnasium in Berlin beginnt der Unterricht auch in Zukunft, die bisher um 8 Uhr morgens. Das hat die Schulkonferenz aus Eltern und Lehrern entschieden. Zuvor hatte schon die Mehrheit der Schüler dagegen gestimmt, die erste Stunde im Winter künftig erst um 9 Uhr beginnen zu lassen. Es war das erste Mal, dass Schüler in Berlin über den Unterrichtsbeginn abgestimmt haben. Die Bundesregierung will mehr Geld für die Abwrackprämie zum Kauf von neuen Autos ausgeben. Darauf haben sich Bundeskanzlerin Merkel und Vizekanzler Steinmeier geeinigt. Wie viel Geld zusätzlich bereitgestellt werden soll, steht noch nicht fest. Für die Abwrackprämie stehen bislang 1, 5 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung. Wer ein neues Auto kauft und sein altes verschrottet, bekommt 2500 Euro. Die Kfz-Branche geht davon aus, dass das Geld schon in den nächsten Wochen aufgebraucht sein wird. Die Weltraum-Faire Discovery ist nach zwei Wochen an der internationalen Weltraumstation ISS auf dem Weg zurück zur Erde. Die sieben Raumfahrer sollen am Samstag landen. Die Besatzung hatte in drei Außeneinsätzen Sonnensiegel installiert und Wartungsarbeiten durchgeführt. In der Basketball-Bundesliga hat Albert Berlin mit 84 zu 69 gegen Ulm gewonnen. Damit hat Albert nur noch zwei Punkte Rückstand auf den Tabellenführer Oldenburg. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen an der Münde 1 Grad, Cottbus 2, Potsdam, Frankfurt, Wittenberger und Europin 3 und in Berlin auch 3 Grad. Die Temperaturen gehen in der Nacht auf bis zu minus 2 Grad runter. Dazu gibt es viele Wolken und besonders im Südwesten zeitweise etwas Regen oder Schnee. Morgen dann weiter stark bewölkt und immer wieder Regen in Richtung Uckermark soll aber auch öfter mal die Sonne rauskommen. Das Ganze bei maximal 9. Uns lieben keine Meldungen vor euch. Allen eine gute Fahrt.
Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr waren es mit Benjamin Eisel um 5 nach halb 12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Berlin, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio auf Fritz für die Statistiker und Freunde der Strichlisten. Wir sind im Teil 144. Peter Frank ist hier, Starbark ist da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden heute über Datenverlust und vor allen Dingen auch Datenrettung. Haben schon ganz viel erfahren, was passiert, wenn die Festplatte nicht mehr die Daten ausspuckt, die da eigentlich drauf sind. Eure Fragen könnt ihr gerne am Telefon loswerden unter 0331 70 97 110. Die nächste Frage kommt aus Berlin von Jessie. Wunderbar und guten Abend. Wo ist das Problem?
Also mein Problem ist, dass ich, also ich muss von ganz vorne anfangen. Also ich arbeite als Bauzeichner und muss somit halt mit meinem Computer arbeiten und gehe nebenbei noch zur Schule und habe meinen großen Computer, also mein, wie nennt sich das? PC, genau, habe ich schon mal gelernt. Hab ich nie ans Internet angeschlossen, weil ich mir immer so dachte, okay in Ordnung kein Internet, da hast du deine Zeichnungen drauf, externe Festplatte, du bist gegen alles sicher.
Richtig.
Ja, bin ich nicht, weil ich musste jetzt meinen Desktop-PC komplett platt machen, weil er hat nämlich auf meinem Bildschirm gemacht, was er wollte und nicht das, was ich wollte. Und ich habe einen komischen Wurm in meinem Ding und auf meiner Festplatte, auf meiner externen Festplatte. Und meine externe Festplatte, so klug wie ich war, habe ich zu so einem Typen gebracht, der halt PC-Mensch sich nennt. Ja, und hab die dann erstmal, er hat gesagt, ja, ist in Ordnung, ist alles schick und ich musste ein paar Zeichnungen löschen, aber ist alles hier in Ordnung. Hab den an meinen Laptop angeschlossen, wo ich an jedem Programm drauf habe. Und dann hat er mir gesagt, dass da dieser Virus wieder drauf ist. Ich da wieder hingerannt, okay in Ordnung. Der Virus ist also, dieser Wurm ist immer noch drauf. Okay in Ordnung, ich mach's noch mal runter. Eine Woche gewartet, hab dieses Ding wieder angeschlossen und mein Laptop hat sich fast im Kreis gedreht, weil er wieder irgendeinen Wurm gefunden hat. Ich hab sie aber zwischendurch nirgendswo angeschlossen. Also sie war nirgendswo nur da. Und er hat mir auch gezeigt, also ich hab bei ihm ein Anzivieren-Programm und als ich wieder gekommen bin nach Hause, hab ich auch ein Anzivieren-Programm gemacht. Da war nichts. Ich hab sie ausgemacht und jetzt ist er wieder da. Was mach ich? Und wie krieg ich meine Zeichnung darunter? Ohne, dass ich wieder so vieler verliere. Und am besten so erklären, dass ich es auch verstehe.
Okay, die Antwort, die ist ein bisschen länger fürchtig und geht auch nicht so pauschal, denn... Also die Zeichnungen sind, dass die gute Nachricht ist, dass mit den Zeichnungen ist eigentlich gar kein Problem. Denn die Zeichnungen, die sollten eigentlich keinen ausführbaren Code enthalten. Insofern kann man die einfach auf einen anderen Datenträger kopieren und das auch ohne jede Gefahr im Allgemeinen. Also ich weiß ja nicht, welches Programm diese Zeichnung erzeugt hat, aber... AutoCAD hat nach meines Wissens keinen ausführbaren Code in den Zeichnungslateien drin. Das heißt, die kann man einfach woanders hin kopieren und da gibt es überhaupt keine Probleme. Der schwierigere Teil ist, was das mit diesem Wurm auf sich hat. Und... Da gibt es sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Es kann zum Beispiel... Eine Möglichkeit ist, dass irgendeine Datei auf dieser externen Festplatte eine Beitfolge oder praktisch eine Signatur hat, die ein bestimmtes Antiviren-Programm als Schadsoftware erkennt, obwohl es gar keine ist. Das wäre dann der false positive Fall. Das kann passieren, gerade wenn Sie sagen, dass der andere Mensch mit seinem Antiviren-Programm diesen offenbar nicht finden konnte. Dann kann es natürlich weiterhin sein, also diese Schadsoftware-Programme sind zum Teil so intelligent, dass sie sich halt möglicherweise auf Ihrem Laptop eingenistet haben. Und dass das unter Umständen erst dann in Erscheinung tritt, wenn Sie diesen Datenträger anschließen, aber eigentlich die ganze Zeit da ist. Also es gibt viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Ich hab bei meinem Freund, der hat ja auch mal noch ein Laptop, und der ist jetzt monatelweise immer in Bayern, und der hat ihn auch angeschlossen. Bei ihm hat sich das auch überschlagen. Der ist aber nie wieder neu. Den hat er vor drei Monaten gekauft, und seitdem war er nie wieder hier.
Also hast du irgendeine Ekelhaftigkeit auf dieser Platte?
Richtig, aber die hab ich nicht nur auf meiner Platte. Ich bin der Meinung, ich hab ja ein kleines bisschen Ahnung, dass auf meinem großen desktop PC in dieser DOS-Abteilung dieser Wurm sitzt.
Wir können die Sache ein bisschen abkürzen, um dich wieder aus dem Würgegriff des Wurms zu befreien. Einen sauberen Rechner nehmen, alle Zeichnungen runter kopieren, Platte neu formatieren und die Zeichnungen wieder drauf kopieren. Dann kann der Wurm eigentlich nicht mehr drauf sein.
Also ich würde auch sagen, du hast den Desktop nicht am Netz gehabt, aber dadurch, dass du die Platten umgesteckt hast, ist das auch ein Verbreitungsweg für den Wurm. Das heißt, der ist dann halt nicht über das Netz gekommen, sondern über deine ex-NFS-Platte. Und der wird halt garantiert auch da drauf sein. Und wenn das Tool es nicht gefunden hat und ihn richtig runtergelöscht hat, dann ist er halt irgendwie beim nächsten Mal dann auch wieder drauf. Das heißt irgendwie...
Wobei man dazu noch sagen muss, dass eine grundsätzliche Einschränkung von Virenscannern ist, dass die grundsätzlich nur das erkennen, was sie kennen. Und dass dort draußen noch wesentlich mehr Schadsoftware unterwegs ist, als das, was die Virenscanner erkennen. Und somit ist dieses ganze Konzept eigentlich grundsätzlich schon lückenhaft. Und das ist aber, denke ich, Material für eine weitere Sendung. Insofern können wir die hier erst mal nur diesen praktischen Tippen geben.
Also wenn du wirklich sicher gehen willst, um das was das Peter gerade gesagt hat, wirklich die Daten, also wirklich die Zeichnungen separat runter kopieren, alles platt machen, wieder rausspielen, dann solltest du sicher sein.
Und im Zweifelsfall aus der externen Platte einfach eine schöne Blumenbank machen und wieder neue zulegen, so dramatisch, weil das sind dir halt zu teilen.
Als Briefbespieler wird sie für sich auch ganz gut machen.
Jesse, vielen Dank, wir hoffen wir haben geholfen. Und es gibt noch ein Problem von John. Hallo John, guten Abend.
Grüß dich, was ist los? Ich hatte, ich merke jetzt live, und da geht das Gespräch in die Richtung. Und zwar in die Richtung logische Schäden. Weil da unterhalte ich natürlich ein Virus auch, oder ein Boom auch einordnen. Das Problem am Anfang wurde relativ viel über Testplattenrücksicherung und Testplattenoperatur geredet, für den Fall, dass die Festplatte wirklich kaputt ist. Was allerdings jetzt in meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen ist, dass ein Rade 5 nichts vor einem logischen Schaden schützt. Also kann ich noch so viel Rade Level in mein Festplattensystem einbauen, wenn ich einen Boom habe, der meine Festplatte befähigt, oder meine Daten beschädigt, da werden die natürlich auf alle anderen Platten in diesem Rade mit repliziert, diese Schäden.
Ja, man kann eigentlich, also ein Rade ist ja eigentlich nur die Abstraktion für eine Festplatte, die aus mehreren Festplatten besteht und die ein gewisses Maß an Redundanz drin hat. Ein Rade verhält sich ja im Grunde genommen gegenüber dem Betriebssystem genauso wie eine einzelne Festplatte. Das heißt also da braucht man dann aus logischer Sicht keinen Unterschied machen, ob das eine einzelne Festplatte oder ein Rade ist.
Und von der Seite würde mich interessieren, ob es da Vorschläge gibt, zum Beispiel wie und mit welchen Tools ich überprüfen kann, ob die Daten auf meinen Sicherungskopien also es muss nicht immer unbedingt ein laufendes Rade-System sein, es könnte auch mal eine USB-Festplatte sein, auf die ich jetzt in meiner Naivität gigabyteweise an Daten schaufe. Und irgendwann geht die eine von den Platten kaputt, da weiß ich, ich habe irgendwo noch eine andere Platte liegen, möchte von dieser Platte die Daten wieder runterholen. Und es stellt dann fest, dass ich ein total chaotisch unorganisierter Mensch bin und gar nicht mehr weiß, welche Daten jetzt überhaupt noch wo liegen. Und mir deswegen auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher sein kann, dass die Daten auf dieser USB-Festplatte jetzt überhaupt noch konsistent sind.
Na gut, also gegen Chaos im Kopf kann die Technik kaum helfen, das ist ganz klar.
Das Chaos steigt ja mit den steigenden Datenträgerkapazitäten, mit den entsprechenden Mengen an Daten, die dann auf die Festplatten drauf kopiert werden. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einen logischen Fehler auf einer Platte habe, aber diesen Fehler immer munter resiziere, auf meine ganzen Backups, und dann irgendwann mal das Backup von 2002 wegschmeiße, wo ich der Meinung bin, irgendwann ist mein Zernschrank voll, dann hab ich natürlich nie gemerkt, dass meine superschönen Bildsammlungen alle schon die eine oder andere, ich würde das mal so ein Kratzer haben.
Da gibt es zwei relativ kurze Antworten drauf. Die eine Antwort ist, dass das ein System, wie man nennt es, das Problem von Backups ist, dass wenn man sie wegschmeißt, dass man sie dann nicht mehr hat. Und die zweite Antwort ist, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, ein Backup zu verifizieren, das Zurückspielen und Durchprobieren aller einzelnen Dateien ist, womit die andere Frage dann glaube ich auch beantwortet ist.
Wobei, die Frage nach dem Tool noch offen wäre. Was wäre jetzt die praktische Variante, wenn ich eine 200 GB auf 500 GB Festplatte habe, mit entsprechend vielen Backups, mach ich immer, mach immer brav eine Spiegelung oder eine Synchronisation auf eine zweite USB-Platte?
Na dann überprüfst du nachher, ob die Daten wirklich konsistent sind, also ob sie miteinander übereinstimmen. Also kannst du einen Hash auf die eine Platte machen, einen Hash auf die eine weite Platte machen, einfach vergleichen. Wenn sie übereinstimmen, hast du auf jeden Fall eine 1 zu 1 Kopie gemacht. Und irgendwie alles andere, was später passiert, hast du dann halt irgendwie nicht im Griff. Also wenn irgendwie die Bits umkippen, weil du die Platte irgendwie in einem Sonnenlicht gelagert hast, dann kannst du irgendwie halt auch mit irgendwelchen Tools nichts mehr irgendwie reißen.
Und Grundvoraussetzung Nummer eins ist, Chaos im Kopf erstmal sortieren.
Na ich glaube, was du meintest, ist, wie kannst du sicherstellen, dass die Dateien, die du dort weggespeichert hast, tatsächlich einen Sinn ergeben? Und die Antwort darauf ist, das kannst du nur feststellen, indem du sie individuell überprüfst, ob sie einen Sinn ergeben.
Das heißt, in der Konsequenz müsste ich dann versuchen, die Ordnung vorher zu schaffen und weniger Daten...
Also das würde auf jeden Fall... Ordnung vorher schaffen macht auf jeden Fall weniger Arbeit als Ordnung hinterher schaffen.
Ja, auch John wird dieses Wochenende wahrscheinlich eine ganze Zeit vor seinem Rechner setzen und das alles wieder sortieren.
Ich hatte unter anderem auch das Problem, weil so einfach ist es mit der einfachen Synchronisation über zwei Platten auch nicht, wenn man halt über mehrere Plattengenerationen wächst.
Ich verstehe dein Problem.
Wenn man mit einer Gigabyte Platte anfängt, dann immer auf eine 250er, dann irgendwo liegt da noch eine 500 Gigabyte Platte rum.
Du glaubst gar nicht, wie ich dein Problem verstehe, weil ich habe so viele Notebooks saved 2004, 2005 auf meinen Rechnern zu liegen. Schmeiß die Daten einfach weg und wenn du nicht weißt, was drauf ist, dann hat es einfach keinen Sinn.
Es ist manchmal noch ganz befreiend, sich von Dingen zu trennen, John. Sag einfach Ja dazu.
Oder warte auf deinen nächsten Platten, dann wird für dich entschieden.
Probier es aus, du bist ein neuer Mensch.
Da habe ich vielleicht noch eine Sache zum Thema.
Dann mach schnell, weil es rennt jetzt wirklich ein bisschen die Zeit weg.
Ganz schnell, einer der vorhergehende Anrufer hat gesagt, er sichert seine Daten auf TrueCrypt-Containern. Das ist eine nette Sache. Also links sollte man die Header der TrueCrypt-Container mitsichern, weil in den ersten, glaube ich, vier Kilobyte oder so stehen die Schlüsse drin. Und wenn die weg sind, dann nutzen einem die restlichen wie viel Gigabyte das auch immer sind, nichts mehr.
Das ist wohl selbstverständlich, dass du alle Daten sicherst.
Genau, bei allen verschlüsselten Lösungen immer die Header-Dateien und die Keys sichern. Oder so einen Keyback abmachen, so ein Reversal.
Das ist ein guter Tipp, ist nicht in allen Fällen notwendig. Ich würde sowieso sagen, dass Full Device Encryption auf jeden Fall besser ist als irgendwelche Container. Aber auf jeden Fall, guter Rat, sichert die Schlüssel mit. Und ein zweiter guter Rat, verschlüsselt eure Platten.
Ja, Chaosradio geht langsam so ein bisschen im Ende entgegen. Wir haben jetzt ganz viel über Datenrettung und Datensicherung gesprochen und Daten wieder zurückholen. Aber es gibt ja auch Daten auf Platten, wo ich sage, die möchte ich nicht mehr, die haue ich jetzt weg. Ich werde diese Daten auf der Platte löschen. Das gibt unterschiedliche Theorien, was dazu zu machen sind. Wie oft zum Beispiel müssen die Sektoren auf so einer Festplatte überschrieben werden, bis das wirklich weg ist? Also wie lösche ich meine Festplatte so, dass auch du, Peter, da nicht mehr noch irgendwelche Sachen drauf findest?
Also da gibt es auch eine sehr einfache und eine sehr schwierige Antwort drauf.
Dann möchte ich erst die einfache.
Die einfache Antwort ist, es genügt, wenn du dafür sorgen möchtest, dass ich einen Sektor nicht mehr lesen kann, dann genügt es, diesen einmal zu überschreiben mit einem Inhalt deiner Wahl. Also wir reden jetzt von modernen Festplatten. Lass uns jetzt nicht in die Oldschool-Geschichte. Wenn du heute eine Festplatte aus dem Laden holst und du hast sie einmal überschrieben, dann sind die Daten weg.
Also früher war es ja, weißt du, das gibt ja die mehr, dass man irgendwie 35 mal überschreiben sollte oder irgendwie alte Tools haben auch immer einen Counter, wie oft man die Daten überschreiben hat. Das war aus dem Grund, dass halt früher die Platten mit so großen Toleranzen gearbeitet haben, dass halt irgendwie nicht auf dem gleichen auf dem gleichen Spur praktisch die Daten geschrieben wurden, sondern halt immer leicht versetzt. Das heißt, wenn du sie einmal überschrieben hast, konnte man eventuell durch die Restmagnetisierung auf den Spur daneben halt um die Daten noch auslesen und wieder rekonstruieren. Das ist irgendwie halt heute nicht mehr so, weil einfach die Motoren, die ganzen...
Na ich glaube, ich kann es erklären. Also die Schreibtichte ist so weit so weit gestiegen, dass die Spuren standardmäßig im Normalbetrieb der Platten schon leicht überlappen. Das heißt also, dass im Grunde genommen die Spur rechts die Spur links schon ein bisschen überschreibt und die Spur links die Spur rechts schon ein bisschen überschreibt. Und dadurch gibt es dazwischen praktisch nichts mehr und ich könnte jetzt auch ganz tief in die Theoriekiste greifen und von 747 Kurven und was weiß ich, was alles reden. Dafür haben wir nicht mehr die Zeit heute, deswegen lassen wir das.
Kannst du auf den Kongress mal machen.
Tatsache, es jedenfalls einmal überschreiben reicht, aber jetzt muss ich leider auch die schlechte Nachricht noch mit dazu bringen. Die schlechte Nachricht ist nämlich, dass ich nur sehr schwer entscheiden kann, welchen physikalischen Sektor ich denn nun überhaupt mit meinem Schreibzugriff erreicht habe. Denn diese Platten sind heute sowas von intelligent, da sind teilweise leistungsfähige Prozessoren auf den Platten-Elektroniken als in dem Rest von dem Rechner. Und die tun da allerhand. Und was die eben auch tun, ist, dass die die Sektor umnummerieren. Das heißt also, wenn ich sage, ich beschreibe jetzt den Sektor 23, dann kann ich ohne tiefste Kenntnis dieser Controller und deren Firmware eigentlich nicht vorhersagen, wo dieser Sektor auf der Platte, oder noch schlimmer ist es bei Solid-State-Discs, wo dieser Sektor, in welchem Chip der Solid-State-Discs dieser Sektor eigentlich landet.
Also ist es inzwischen auch bei Festplatten so?
Es ist auch bei Festplatten so, ja. Es ist bei Festplatten nicht ganz so schlimm, da ist die Zuordnung zwischen der LBA, also der logischen Blockadresse, und dem tatsächlichen physikalischen Speicherort auf dem Medium etwas dichter als bei Solid-State-Discs. Aber sie ist nicht ohne tiefere Kenntnis des Controllers und seiner Firmware vorhersehbar. Und das Problem ist also nicht, wie oft überschreibe ich den Sektor, sondern die Frage ist, habe ich ihn überhaupt getroffen? Und diese Frage ist wirklich, da könnten wir jetzt noch eine Extrasendung machen, wie überschreibe, also wie stelle ich fest, ob ich oder kann ich überhaupt feststellen, welchen Sektor ich denn nun wirklich physikalisch überschrieben habe. Tatsache ist jedenfalls, es macht überhaupt gar keinen Unterschied, ob ich diesen Sektor einmal oder eben diese vorgeschlagenen, weiß ich nicht, hundertmal nicht überschrieben habe. Das Ergebnis ist das gleiche, er ist noch da.
Okay, das heißt, die Alternative ist dann halt wirklich die Gausser, also wirklich mit elektromagnetischem Puls so auf die Daten, auf die magnetischen Ausrichtungen einzuhauen, dass wir sich dann...
Das ist ja kein elektromagnetischer Puls, also wir wollen es ja nicht übertreiben, das ist einfach nur ein Magnetfeld. Also man kann natürlich mit einem Magnetfeld, was deutlich höher als die Koalzitivfeldstärke des Mediums ist, und jetzt wollen wir auch nicht zu tief in die Physik gehen, kann man die Ausrichtung, kann man die Ausrichtung dieser magnetischen Oberfläche löschen. Aber auch das ist nicht so einfach, denn auch das kann ich ja letztlich wirklich nur vorhersehbar tun, wenn ich das Medium aus der Festplatte ausbaue, denn sonst habe ich eine ganze Menge Metalle dazwischen, die zu einer Veränderung des eingestrahlten Magnetfeldes führen, zu einer Abschwächung oder auch zu einer Umlenkung. Und so ist es, es ist wirklich eine sehr schwierige Thematik, ich denke, wir sollten da bei dem, also wir sollten da bei dem, bei dem überschreiben bleiben, also ein, ein für Privatverhältnisse vernünftiger Weg, eine Platte vor dem Weiterverkauf über eBay oder der Entsorgung oder was weiß ich zu löschen, also ein vernünftiger und machbarer Weg ist, bei einer Festplatte einfach ein DD von Def Zero auf dem, auf Sektor 0 bis letzten, bis letzte LBA der Festplatte. Und dann kann man zumindest sagen, habe ich einen großen Teil der Daten, den größten Teil, beseitigt, so dass ich mir keine Sorgen machen muss, dass da irgendjemand das wiederfinden wird. Nur da liegt eben die Tücke im Detail. Es werden einzelne Sektoren infolge des Defect-Managements ausgelagert, die erreiche ich dann natürlich nicht mehr, weil ich sie als, weil die gar keine LBA-Adresse mehr haben. Also kann ich sie vom Rechner aus gar nicht mehr adressieren. Es gibt so Spielereien wie die sogenannte Host-Protected Area oder eben Arta Setmax. Also wer sich den Arta-Standard durchliest, der wird da die lustigsten Dinge feststellen, dass man da auch praktisch per Arta-Kommando die Festplatten in verschiedenen, also verkleinern kann, praktisch sizeen kann, sodass man einen Teil praktisch restlos vor dem Controller verbirgt. Den wird man natürlich damit auch nicht erreichen, denn da kann Linux oder DD auch nichts dran tun. Das lässt sich nur mit speziellen Arta-Kommandos wieder freisetzen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn ich den Sektor erreicht habe bei einer modernen Festplatte und habe ihn überschrieben, und zwar meine ich jetzt den Sektor hardwaremäßig auf dem Medium. Ich meine jetzt nicht den Sektor, den ich denke, der die LWA-Adresse hat, die ich angegeben hat. Also wenn ich den einmal überschrieben habe, dann ist der nicht mehr wieder herzustellen.
Aber soll die Grundaussage schon halt irgendwie löschen oder einfach nur wirklich als löschen markieren, bzw. formatieren, reicht halt nicht aus, weil man wirklich die Daten mindestens einmal überschreiben, dass sie halt sicher weg sind.
Ich muss sie vollständig überschreiben, damit sie weg sind. Das ist richtig.
Wie sieht es bei SSD oder bei CDs aus?
Bei SSD ist da ein ganz großes Problem, denn die Aufgabe des SSD-Controllers ist eben möglichst wenig Daten an die gleiche Stelle zu schreiben, weil die Flashzellen eine begrenzte Lebensauer haben. Das heißt, jeder SSD-Controller versucht, die Schreibzugriffe gleichmäßig auf alle Flashzellen zu verteilen. Und wie macht er das? Sagen wir mal, ich schreib jetzt 100.000 Mal den Sektor 0 neu. Na was wird der machen? Intern in seiner kleinen Organisation da drinnen, schreib ich, wenn ich das erste Mal, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal ein doofes Beispiel, ich schreib das erste Mal den Sektor 0, dann wird er den Hardware Sektor 0 überschreiben. Jetzt schreib ich denselben Sektor nochmal, wieder Sektor 0, dann denkt er, ups Sektor 0 hab ich gerade geschrieben, jetzt muss ich einen anderen nehmen, nehmt er Sektor 1. Wenn ich jetzt 100.000 Mal geschrieben hab, dann hab ich jetzt praktisch 100.000 Kopien dieses Sektors in 100.000 Flash Sektoren dupliziert. Das heißt, ich hab jetzt 100.000 Kopien des selben Sektors in meinem Flash.
Und so richtig gewonnen hast du nichts.
Das heißt, hier ist überschreiben also deutlich kontraproduktiv. Weil beim überschreiben, im Grunde genommen, ich überhaupt erst wieder Sektoren nimm, die schon mal gebraucht sind, wenn er alle, die noch nicht gebraucht sind, zu Ende verbraucht hat.
Das heißt wirklich auch auf der Hardware-Ebene zerstören, also mit dem Hammer raufhauen oder?
Ja, naja, auch das muss nicht unbedingt helfen. Ich meine, ich kann den Chip auch auseinander holen.
Wie macht man es denn wirklich ordentlich?
Und rebonden. Also, okay. Also wenn man es wirklich ordentlich machen will, also da kann ich dir jetzt keinen praxistauglichen Tipp geben. Ich kann dir nur sagen, wenn du jetzt die Flashchips natürlich rausholst und du fängst an, die Planes direkt auf dem Chip zu eräsern, dann kannst du natürlich sicher sein, dass sie weg sind.
Das ist ein bisschen viel Aufwand.
Aber durch die Schnittstelle hindurch gibt es keine sichere Möglichkeit, eine SSD zu löschen. Das ist, glaube ich, das ist das, was man so rausgeben kann für die Leute, die es wissen wollen. Also SSD löschen per Software nein.
Und CD ist Mikrowelle?
Mikrowelle ist ziemlich effizient bei CD.
Aber danach nicht mehr essen. Wir kommen so ein bisschen zum Ende der Sendung. Wir könnten noch stundenlang weitermachen. Wie Peter schon sagte, es gibt einige Fachgebiete, wo wir da noch weitere Sendungen dazu zaubern wollen. Vielleicht zum Abschluss noch mal ganz kurz die drei wichtigsten Sachen, die wir uns alle ins Hausaufgabenheft schreiben zum Thema Wie kriege ich meine Daten sicher? Wenn wir über Festplatten reden, Peter.
Die drei wichtigsten Sachen, naja, also...
Kopieren, also Sicherheitskopie machen, auslagern, also nicht zu Hause lagern, sondern wirklich an einem anderen Ort auch, weil es irgendwie Feuer gibt.
Wenn die Festplatte Geräusche macht, lasst den Strom weg davon.
Genau, also das, ja, genau. Wenn es ein Physikale, also wenn es ein logisches Problem ist, erst ein Image davon anfertigen, auf einer anderen Platte und da drauf rumspielen. Wenn sich dabei ein Problem herausstellt bei diesen Imagen, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein physikalisches Problem. So wie auch wenn die Platten Geräusche machen und dann kann man im Regelfall selber nichts mehr tun. Dann braucht es einen Reihenraumlabor und dann, wenn einem die Daten lieb sind, muss man sofort den Strom abschalten.
Das war Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 144. Vielen Dank Peter, vielen Dank Starbuck, dass ihr hier wart. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, hier geht es gleich weiter mit den Kollegen vom Night Flight. Max, Smart und Konsorten sind am Start. Werden euch jetzt hier biet zum die Ohren hauen, dass die Wände wackeln. Wir hören uns spätestens in vier Wochen wieder zum nächsten Chaosradio, die Sendung nochmal hören. Geht natürlich als Podcast entweder auf fritz.de oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Bis demnächst. Tschüss, machts gut.